Hello everybody welcome to welcome in!
Mimi!
Hello!
Hello everybody!
Welcome, welcome, welcome!
Hi!
Hello!
Happy weekend!
Happy, happy weekend!
I hope you guys have been having a good one.
How are we doing?
Love this game so much.
Actor is peaking everything.
Saw your body.
I'm really happy that you enjoyed Ace Combat 7.
I have a lot of respect for that game despite not being my
favorite in the series.
That's a lot of people have said.
But since it's the only one that I've played, of course I
can not.
I have to say it's my favorite.
So far.
Snowed in.
Stay warm.
Me too.
I'm staying warm.
I've been drinking, I've just been like chugging warm drinks
all day.
Otherwise my ectoplasm will freeze.
Hello, Amito and I booze like you.
I hope your day has been good so far.
My ice fishing tournament got cancelled because the ice got
too thin.
Well, I thought you were about to say because of the ice,
which I was going to say that's so ironic.
No!
Already?
Siberia!
Welcome to Babusha, thank you.
I'm stoked always wanted to see this game in action.
Tim Folin's music is the cherry on top.
Well, you'll see it in action.
Literally live action.
We're gonna see real people.
Flesh.
Fleshies.
Flesh...
Actual...
Like if...
Okay, take a mirror.
Look at yourself.
That's what we'll be seeing.
You.
You've been stuck in the game.
Wake up.
Y'all are in for a treat.
This game is a gem.
I'm excited.
I mean, that was my birthday.
I turned redacted.
Could I get a happy birthday?
Sedario!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
The game kind of saved the franchise, though.
It could be the...
Wait.
It could have been the last game in the series.
too it went through multiple delays yeah I remember I
remember that all the development like hearing about the
development how that it went through yeah genuinely thought
that said chef clues oh you said you said that and then I
also saw I was like I I saw it but I also processed the chef
we should hold I'm gonna read the case background info and
then we will watch the prologue because I haven't watched it
yet or anything.
The victim.
Kate Vine was a PhD student found drowned at midnight last
Friday in a lake in the woods on the outskirts of the tiny
village of Edenton.
I don't know why I assumed that oh my gosh her dimples are
so cute.
She's so cute.
I assumed that this was going to be like a Scooby-Doo case,
not a murder.
The lab report indicated a high level of alcohol in her
blood at the time of death, along with traces of morphine.
The alcohol is consistent with her medical records, which
reveal a history of depression and alcoholism.
Oh, no, Kate.
However, the origin of the morphine remains a mystery.
It goes places.
Oh, I'm so...
I know nothing.
I'm so excited.
I'm ready to go, places.
places take me places so Scooby-Doo Kate had joined a
controversial business course called Atlas based in a large
stately home just outside the village oh oh wait British who
says village wait a second oh wait British Kate we are so
British.
Someone call Vicky.
Get her people.
Kate had been attending the course on the night of her
death.
Atlas is run by father and son, teen Paul and Ryan Rand.
Paul and Ryan Rand.
Both were interviewed following Kate's death, but neither
claimed to have seen Kate after the meeting and both were
understandably eager to distance themselves and from the
tragedy.
This isn't the first time Atlas has been investigated.
Oh, oh.
Rumors have been circulating for years surrounding Atlas and
their questionable methods, which many have suggested border
on mind control.
Where can I sign up?
Rebecca Rand.
Ryan is married to Rebecca.
Landlady.
Landlady You have Edenton's village pub.
Oh, no, you're so British.
The George and Dragon.
As yet, she hasn't been interviewed.
Me too?
Hi, that's me.
Yes, yes.
As the hub of the village, the pub...
The hub of the...
The hub is the pub.
The pub will have been known to most of the villagers and
Rebecca has often hosted local bands and village events.
Also, given Kate's alcoholism, it's likely she visited the
pub on more than one occasion.
The only place to drink in town.
Okay, it's not even a town.
It's a village.
Only place to drink in village.
Simon and Emma.
We're getting the whole cat.
Look at the...
This is what's it called?
The...
The shot.
the headshot.
This is the headshot.
I appreciate you lots.
We tell your voice and energy always lives my spirits.
Keep warm.
You too, Phoenix.
Thank you.
Rocky.
Welcome to Mambusha, back you.
Who's Emma?
E.
No, it's E.
B.
Emma Bowman.
E.
One of Kate's friends from college was Emma Bowman.
who lives with boyfriend Simon at Eden Lodge on the road to
the woods.
Simon Thompson met Emma at university.
After completing his degree 18 months ago, he went to work
at a shop in the neighboring village.
I'm not going to remember any of these people, I think.
I think so.
Uh-huh, me-duh.
Uh-huh.
I agree.
Emma was shocked to hear of Kate's death.
She didn't attend Atlas, but Simon joined a few months ago.
I didn't see Kate after the meeting but seemed unmoved by
her death.
You are feeling very yabai.
Am I getting hypnotized?
Are you trying to hypnotize me?
I have a mind of steel, baby.
Mind of steel.
You'll get nothing out of me.
Yeah, Nan, I'll be playing Ace Combat.
Hopefully soon.
I'm excited for 8 too.
If Minto haunted an elevator, she could have her spirit
lifted too.
That sounds dangerously close to going to heaven.
Also, I think you should check out the game Who's Lila?
You might like it.
Oh.
Why do you think I might like it?
Shall we watch the pro lot?
Wait a second.
Oh, okay.
This is the...
I was like, wait.
Where do we start the game?
Hold on.
Let me read the instructions too.
Kate Vine drowned in a lake in the woods just outside.
Oh wow, the pub.
Wow, wow!
We're going!
We're going to the UK!
Last, last Friday night.
The game starts one week later.
On Friday at 5 p.m.
You can guide...
I thought this said jerks.
We're taking jerks around the village in two ways.
You can follow the direction arrows to move to adjacent
locations.
Okay, so it's just like a point and click.
That's easy.
Hello, Kate.
When you're waiting at a location, you can open your
inventory, scroll through your collected items, which
includes physical objects and information.
Jerks has collected.
That's his name now.
That's his name.
Physical items can sometimes be used.
The hand symbol is shown, which you can select, okay?
I probably...
Hold on.
You can also see previous replies.
to each item.
I either clicking beneath the description or pressing the
left controller.
They expect me to play this game with a controller?
What did this come out on?
Wait.
Huh?
What?
It's a investigation time with Minto.
Yeah.
Jogs.
The jogsler.
The jengsler.
The jerksler.
It's the one and only PS5 game.
It's five exclusive.
Astro Bot.
I am out.
Okay, we got this.
I've played games before.
Let's watch the prologue.
My name is Jenks.
Detective Inspector Frederick Jenks.
I thought it was one name man.
I've been assigned to a last minute investigation into the
death of Kate Vine.
A PhD student.
found drowned at midnight last Friday in a lake in the woods
on the outskirts of the tiny village of Edenton I have until
first thing tomorrow morning to decide whether her death was
a simple accident or whether this was murder murder Kate
Vine appeared to the world to be a bright confident
fun-loving PhD student with everything to live for tomorrow
yeah what a history of depression and alcoholism revealed in
her medical records suggests that in reality she Oh my god,
we went inside!
Oh my god, we went inside!
Along with the late hour of her death, and a lack of
witnesses, makes a strong case that this was suicide.
But the verdict overlooked some curious details.
Curious.
Why was her driving license found on the opposite side of
the lake in which she drowned?
Oh!
Also, there were traces of morphine in Kate's sister.
Where did she get it?
Kate was known to be a free spirit with a nihilistic love of
danger, in part have something to do with a business course
called atlas which kate had joined and which she had been
attending on the night of her death based in a large stately
home on the outskirts of the village the exclusive atlas is
run by father and son team paul and ryan rand both were
interviewed following a lot of information really is this a
problem after the meeting and both were understandably eager
to distance themselves and atlas from the tragedy i'm so
curious this isn't What about exploring your past
experience?
Childhood.
What's month five?
Mourning your past!
Taking control of your life!
Ryan is married to Rebecca, landlady of Edenton's village
pub, the George and Dragon.
I feel like we're watching like a Netflix documentary.
Or like a...
Or like one of those true crime YouTube channels or
something.
One of Kate's friends was Emma Bowman, who lives at Eden
Lodge on the road leading out of Edenton Village.
BBC documentary, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But didn't attend Atlas.
Interviewed after Kate's death, Emma seemed shocked and
upset, insisting she hadn't seen Kate that night.
This is all that I just read earlier.
Simon Thompson met Emma at university.
After completing his degree around 18 months ago, he went to
work at a shop in the neighboring village.
But he doesn't care about a few months ago.
Or not Emma.
Simon insisted that he didn't see Kate after the meeting.
interviewing him noted he seemed oddly unmoved by her death
which makes him the first person I want to see tonight Okay,
it's time for some answers Yeah, baby.
It's time for some answers.
Yeah, it's time for some answers.
Let's start the game I can finally drink now one melon soda,
please Come and run up Start the game.
Wait GIM?
GIM?
Uh.
Wait, now I can't click anything.
GIM?
Uh.
It's not letting me click.
Okay, I think I have to reset the game.
Oh, it's not letting me reset the game.
Can I exit the game?
Oh, no.
Wait, I'm stuck in the game.
Wait.
stuck at the game?
Oh, shoot.
Uh.
The first puzzle.
Oh, my gosh.
Should we get stuck?
Okay, let me... F.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
Maybe that will restart it.
No.
My keyboard works, as you can see.
A true detective clears all hurdles.
and enter?
No.
Okay, I'm just gonna task manager close the game.
I think it's this one.
What is this called?
Contradict... It has to be this one.
Okay.
Sorry.
We're restarting the game.
But that's fine.
That's fine.
A bit of a rocky stuff.
Exit game.
Okay, thank you, Steam.
It didn't...
When I close the game... Wait, uh-oh.
Steam?
Okay, okay, we could play again, we could play again.
Okay, we're good, we're good, we're good.
And you guys get to see the sick intro.
It's kind of fun.
Wait, so this is the lake I just got.
Freaky, freaky.
No, no, Janks, no.
If I click to exit, a sign to a last-minute investigation
into the death of Kate Vine, a PhD student found drowned at
midnight last Friday.
Okay, I'm clicking the exit.
Don't take me back to the title.
Okay, we're good.
We just watched that.
Yeah, everyone take notes.
Is this a notes-taking game?
I think it's the type of game that will take the notes for
me, it seems like.
Welcome to Edenton Village.
Click the arrows to move around the village if you see the
magnifying glass, try your investigate to see jenks
investigate oh boy oh click the inventory icon to see your
collected items which include both physical objects and
information jenks has collected if you're at a location
where you think you can use a physical item try the icon if
not will be your notebook yeah okay I'll rely on you guys
and okay let's investigate wait this just shows my My mouse.
It doesn't show, like, a magnifying glass.
You know what I mean?
Oh, oh, just kidding.
Oh.
Hello.
I'm curious if that will be an issue later.
Change some settings.
That's the funny thing.
The game had, like, no settings.
So we have Try using this
There's no use for Kate's lost driving license here Sorry
it's so polite Okay so we're trying to get to Not the rands
We're trying to get to Simon and Emma So we gotta go to the
north lane I'm just clicking everything right now Yeah these
are the only options here
yeah yeah yeah that's okay though we'll figure it out oh do
oh wait i thought it said do better you already need a hint
what the hell you stupid detective do better why are you
already asking for help better do a spot of an better do a
spot of investigating around eden lodge you also have things
you haven't asked simon and emma about okay let's go let's
go ask oh whoa i'm so immersed wait this is a video it's not
a photo oh my god this is so funny
this game was made by the tim fallen the guy who made the
nes picture theme.
Among many other video game theme songs for the NES.
Oh, what?
Crazy.
Uh, we're going, okay, I think it's, uh, how, hold on, I
want to go down this way and see what we have here, though.
The Village Hall.
What's this?
Oh, okay, so this pops up.
Okay, we can, oh.
Oh, always nice to randomly find a key on the floor.
So true, Janks.
so true i love finding keys on the floor and taking them oh
we are investigating some more he's so close life wow isn't
that interesting why you gotta play at dead of night too
wait is it the same team that game scares me i don't think i
could ever play that game it makes me have like oh my gosh i
get i get i get jumpy like crazy with it.
Oh, same devs at that of nine.
The lack of setting is because the entire game is one big
long video file.
Oh, that makes sense.
Wow!
Oh my gosh, we get another view!
Look at the castle!
Oh, it's so cute!
This way.
Here we go.
Minto is British now.
Oh, Minto, Janks.
Thank goodness you're here.
Oh no!
Let's see.
Okay, the Eden Lodge.
Knock for Simon.
Oh, what are we investigating first?
A bike.
Does it got dirt on it from the lake?
Very trusting, leaving a bike unlocked.
I am the one who steals it.
Homebrew equipment.
Oh, we're just digging through the garbage now.
Ah.
This might come in handy.
Oh, okay, we're stealing their things now.
Oh.
Okay.
It was in the garbage right here, so it's fine.
I'm surprised we're not, like, looking, peering through the
windows and everything.
Oh, Simon.
Simon.
Is it Simon?
Uh, yeah.
Detective Inspector Jenks.
I'm investigating an incident in the village.
Could I come in and ask you a few questions, please?
Yeah.
Thank you.
why is he so suspicious he's so sussy looking hmm yeah okay
we can just go through here if you want Emma's working in
the front room it's so loud hi this is inspector James Jenks
Jenks there was a death in the village Kate vine I believe
you both knew her yeah do you need to speak to both of us
I'll just speak to Simon first if that's okay just come
through no no ADR in this game all right oh I got oh I've
got oh oh oh my first interview first pick an item you want
to ask about then click ask to see Jank's ask about it a lot
of times I say ask when you've heard the reply you'll see a
summary of of what was said in the bottom.
Oh, in the box at the bottom.
Simon said blah, blah, blah.
He also said blah, blah.
And he said blah, blah de blah.
Alan Wake writing.
Clicking any item you've already asked about shows the
summary of replies beneath.
Oh, that's handy.
Now click any reply to add it to the contradiction box on
the right.
Oh, wait, maybe I should move.
Like this.
Oh, but then I think I'm blocking the subtitles more.
Alright, guys, we're on the left side today.
Perhaps.
Yeah,
this is fine, probably.
This company also did another mystery FMV called The
Infectious Madness of Dr. Decker.
And I highly recommend it.
That sounds fine.
Misadventure Mysteries?
Yes.
Okay, one second.
Wait.
That should be okay.
Okay, sorry, I'm repositioning some things on my computer.
This game rules have
5-me-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-te-I'm
excited.
Okay.
Contradiction box.
You can start looking...
Now you can start looking for contradictions.
We haven't even asked anything yet.
I don't think we can search.
for we can i don't think we can look at all fine two
contradictory replies and add them to the contradiction box
if they go green sit back and watch jenks interrogate your
interviewee
so ask about okay i noticed a lot of bottles outside are
they yours yeah i'll make home room for yourself well no i
give it out to my friends and stuff i tried selling it at
first but i didn't have any takers except for james over at
farmhouse because It's bad.
I used to trade it to him for herbs and stuff.
Herbs.
Do you see James a lot?
No, not really.
Hmm.
So we have all these things here too.
Simon told Janks about his homebrew.
Let's see.
When was the last time you saw Kate Vine?
Herbs.
Um, so last Friday's meeting, I think.
Did you see her after the meeting?
No.
How long have you known, Kate?
That would be when we started Atlas.
Three months ago?
Did you socialize outside Atlas?
No.
How do you describe her?
The og thing, this thing.
What sort of person was she?
Well, she's talented.
She was full of life, you know.
Sharp, quite sharp.
Would you say she had any emotional problems?
She, her mood, her mood could change.
And, well, there was the drinking problem.
When did you become aware of that?
Well, she would come drunk to a meeting sometimes.
Oh, no.
She would reek of the stuff.
Oh, it might be a pig.
It looks like, I thought it was a she, but you know.
It might be a pig.
Tell me a bit about that.
That was just a business management training program for
post grads.
and you started this after you left college uh yeah and it's
on every friday yeah well this guy's been it's on every
friday okay thanks okay you've only known kate for three
months didn't socialize with kate outside atlas kate often
seemed drunk at atlas i see he's acting he is oh he got her
driver's license dropped silver key it isn't worth worth
asking okay we're gonna ask about his bicycle hmm simon have
you checked on your bicycle in the past 30 minutes uh you
know last i saw it was unlocked and that's not very wise
there could be someone who has come over and uh you know
seen that it was unlocked and so hmm where's the bike
outside Oh, that's my cousin's.
He lent me it.
I need to buy a new lock for it, though.
So it's your bike at the moment.
Yeah, yeah.
There's no bus service to speak of around here, so it's
really the only way to get around.
Uh-huh.
Bike is the only way Simon can get to work.
This town is small.
It really is a village.
Asking because he's going to steal it later.
100%.
It isn't worth asking Simon about this creature.
screwdriver that we stole.
Simon, have you noticed that you're missing a screwdriver
lately?
We took it!
Wait, a screwdriver was found in a box outside Eden Lodge.
Like, it's not yours.
Oh my gosh, okay, let's ask about the driver's license.
whether Kate had lost this or not.
This is bad boy.
Whip it out.
No.
No, I don't think so.
I've never seen it before.
Why do you look at him like that first though?
He doesn't know anything about that.
That was it.
Hold on.
Did you see his face?
Did you know whether Kate had lost this or not?
No.
This?
No, I don't think so.
What was that?
I've never seen it before.
Do you guys know that show?
Oh my gosh.
It's a show.
It's like one of those kind of detective shows.
Except it's about a guy that reads like micro expressions on
people's faces and stuff.
And he like does this thing.
He'll like kind of point at them and like.
Like kind of swipe his finger around.
Be like I see all these micro expressions.
Not the mentalist.
Lie to me.
Yeah that was the show.
Oh I didn't know that the mentalist was also a similar
story.
Janks always has one eyebrow raised higher than the other.
It's so distracting.
Peak dream workspace moment.
I feel like I'm being the main guy and lie to me right now.
Contradictions.
I don't think we have any contradictions.
We have nothing else to ask either.
So let's go visit Emma, I suppose.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
few questions yeah yeah lie to me with tim roth i loved that
yeah let's ask about when was the last time you saw kate
vine it was last thursday in the college library um i saw
her and we chatted for a mm-hmm she seemed her usual self
usual self depressed sad Kate being Kate you know a bit wild
wild what way was it oh she just used to question everything
you know have arguments with the lecturers things like that
what else that's wild Kate had a drink problem how
noticeable was that well it wasn't at first his face is
crazy as the year went on be drunk in the afternoon but i
think she cut down you know towards the end of college and
when she started her phd kate was argumentative at college i
see a mirrored jenks emoji jenks face is trying to leave his
head so hard we don't know but it's a cry for help there's a
there's a tiny man stuck in him stuck in his body and he's
trying to escape his expressions are a cry for help
it's so funny the driver's oh wait so didn't see kate very
often i thought she was friends though
did you know whether kate had lost this or not this um i
don't know but i i don't think so okay okay no it's not
about the key it doesn't matter who's is the bike outside oh
it's simon's cousins he uses it to get to work you know the
locks broke oh i know i keep telling him to fix it you know
the locks broken i checked because i wanted to steal it it's
the homebrew what's the that's all Simon's stuff you better
ask him I I don't know they're dating right isn't that what
I said that Emma and Simon are dating you don't know about
his hobby of homebrewing bottles have you ever tried Simon's
homebrew see no I don't like beer I only drink wine I can't
stand spirits either I feel like we're gonna have a
contradiction there one day Doesn't like beer.
The contradiction.
Emma said she only drinks wine and that she doesn't like
beer.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Okay.
Just to knock on the window for Emma.
Simon always answers the front door.
Oh, we're knocking on the, we are knocking on the window.
Hello.
A few more questions if you don't mind.
No, stinking way.
Okay, never mind.
back later on if that's okay she hates spirits so i hate her
no i'm just kidding all right let's go to the rat oh wait
continue ahead into into the woods into the oh who has this
where the body was found go to the jetty let's go to the
jetty whoa whoa there's people over there investigation day
36 still canvassing the town for who knows about simon's
bike do they we have to ask everybody in town if they know
that the lock is broken just making sure just like a piece
of jewelry there stuck between the boards well and truly
wedged in i can use the screwdriver the screwdriver Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
How do I get to my inventory again?
What's my inventory?
The screwdriver!
Uh, uh, screwdriver!
Try using this!
There we go.
It's a bird.
Interesting.
I thought forensics had checked the whole area.
Obviously not very well.
Oh.
Dang.
How could they miss this very obvious jewelry that was stuck
in, that was completely wedged into the into the pier like
what stupid god they didn't even comb this place with a
metal detector or something crazy take that forensics yeah
we're taking that take that and we're taking your jobs we
already found something we're so good head towards atlas
right into the clearing
okay this is a place relaxing probably haunted now forensics
just couldn't get it out because they forgot to steal a
screwdriver true true the only thing that gets me is now i'm
facing a different way and i kind of lose which direction
i'm supposed to go try using this broken pendant broken
pendant was retrieved near use it no okay wait where am i oh
so this is atlas Paul and Ryan Rand are down here.
Let's go to Atlas, I guess.
See if we can get in.
Oh, we're just standing in the woods.
I mean, I guess that's how we got here.
Oh, we're going in.
Okay, let's go in.
Just kidding.
I have to come back later, I think.
Dang, he's like, he's yanking on that thing.
He's like, maybe it'll break.
just like the lock on Simon's bike.
Everybody in this village uses weak locks.
We need the lock-picking lawyer stat.
That guy would get this open in two seconds.
Try the key!
Oh my gosh, wait, you're so right.
No, it says we can't.
Dang.
We're not ready to break an entry, I guess.
Okay.
Clearing.
Look, you can see the parts in the water.
It's kind of eerie how some things move and some things
don't, you know what I mean?
We didn't go the other opposite way.
Yeah, this one.
Okay.
Just another part.
All right.
Part of the lake.
We got that.
Woods Lane.
Here we go.
I'll get I'll get I'll get the hang of it.
I'll get the hang of it Village center Rebecca's pub.
Hello, will you let me in yet?
It's dark now No
The water looks so CGI graphics are just that good nowadays
Okay, so we're here We're We'll Where are we actually click
a pin or move left and right with those oh i can click can i
like fast travel well now i'm gonna test oh i can okay good
to know oops wrong thing okay that's awesome awesome awesome
behind brandon house hello hello anybody here i'm gonna use
the silver key Okay, I can't...
I thought I could, like, maybe unlock this.
I love the walking animation.
So, it's not even animation, but you know what I mean.
Call the chief.
Hello, chief.
Write that down.
Hello.
You know there's going to be some druids in this town.
What if her?
I think her death was a sacrifice.
I think it has to be.
I think her death has to be a sacrifice for the Atlas
ritual.
Hello, hello, hello.
It always is.
Where the heck am I going?
Okay, now I do need a hint.
Help me.
Oh, oh duh.
I forgot about the...
Oops, sorry.
Maybe key at the bar?
We're really just gonna enter then, huh?
We'll do this and then we can try the...
Emma!
A few more questions.
Cannibals?
I hope so.
Calling it now.
This broken pendant.
Ever seen this?
ever seen looks like uh like a bird that's my old necklace i
gave this to kate so kate might have been wearing it last
friday oh well perhaps but i can't see why she was always
buying new things you know lots of jewelry stuff like that
wait i thought you guys weren't great friends it's meant to
be a bird in cage but the cage's fallen off oh i'll show you
oh where did you buy it i didn't some wanted present secret
admirer that's a secret oh See?
That's how it should have looked.
It's called a freedom necklace.
A freedom necklace.
No?
Not at all.
Wait, so...
So the necklace did belong to Kate.
Interesting.
I'm starting to wish I'd brought a spare evidence bag.
Alex James, London, Paris, New York.
Designed in Puta.
So she gave her like a necklace?
Wait.
kind of an odd gift?
No?
I mean, I don't think it's odd to gift someone jewelry.
I think it's...
I think, I don't know, maybe more odd that she got it as a
gift and like...
and like gave it away to a friend.
It's the re-gifting.
Yeah, that's how I feel about it.
Hmm.
Unwanted gift.
Okay, that's it for now.
Thank you.
um does simon know anything about it a couple more questions
if that's okay i don't think he does you should ask about
the freedom necklace rather yeah that's what i was about to
do yeah you know what this is yeah yeah i think amma had one
like it actually you know what kate had one i remember
because i asked her about it one night when we were all out
drinking in college i was probably pretty drunk that's what
college is all about Kate wore the necklace at college.
Okay.
Wait.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
I should probably ask Emma about the card itself.
My bad.
Wait.
I forgot to ask her.
Emma!
Let me...
I'm imagining like crawling through her window.
You know?
Oh, okay, okay.
Never mind.
We don't need to.
Okay, cool.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
The graphics look so lifelike.
I know, it's crazy, right?
Wow, we're truly in the future.
Okay.
Now let's go to the pub.
Let's see if there's the key we can use.
I don't know, though.
Nope.
Because all I do is knock here.
Yeah, and it just kicks me out.
Okay.
Hi, hi, Minto.
Ritual sacrifice reminds me of the Wickerman.
Nicholas Cage is out.
They're screaming, not the bees.
Yeah, probably.
Probably.
This is the British version of...
Ah, one more thing.
Unreal Engine 7!
Wow.
First look.
Hmm.
We haven't even met anybody else.
what's my thing you know
what was here the village hall hello hello hello
it's a sleepy village yeah so sleepy oh you should call the
chief for an update okay I'm gonna use the hints a little
bit more often while I get used to the game itself but okay
phone box call the chief now he'll answer now he wants to
talk to me
hello hello hello hello hello I've questioned Simon Thompson
and Emma Bowman so far I found a pendant by the lake which
turns out to have been Emma's but Emma gave it to Kate so
chances are Kate was wearing it the night she drowned what
does Thompson know about it Simon doesn't seem to know much
I don't Trust Thompson.
Yeah.
But again, I don't trust Emma that much either.
Oh.
Try and get a bit of background on them.
You know, usual stuff.
When did Emma meet Kate?
How long have they known each other?
Give me a call back when you've got some more.
Thanks, Chief.
Weary.
Okay, thanks, Chief.
Okay, we're going back to knock and all.
Oh, my gosh.
They're going to get so sick of me.
Hello.
Hello, Simon.
Ask you a couple more things, please.
Uh.
Wait...
I thought...
We were gonna ask about more things.
That's all for the moment, thank you.
Okay.
I wanna know, though.
She...
Didn't see Kit very often.
But they were friends, right?
Like...
How do you know Kate bought lots of new jewelry if you
didn't see her very often?
You know?
I'm gonna try it.
I'll try it.
Do I... I guess it... it doesn't work.
I guess if you... hmm.
Let me try it with Simon then because...
Be that later on if that's okay.
They don't say anything.
He just says it himself.
Here, let's see.
Okay, for this though, wore the necklace at college.
Let's see what he said.
Didn't socialize.
Oh, outside of Atlas.
There we go.
That's the contradiction.
Wait.
It said that he went drinking with her.
No.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
I'm just bouncing from person to person.
That's it for the time being.
You're on the right track.
That's really close.
Okay, maybe it's two different prompts.
This is very at dead of night.
It's always just trying to figure out what prompts to use.
You know?
Um.
I wonder if it's the only known for three months.
And then.
Or the necklace at college.
Ah!
Oh!
So how did you know Kate was wearing a freedom necklace 18
months ago?
At college.
Hey, yeah.
Well, I knew Kate at college, but I didn't get to know her
till we started at Atlas.
Right.
So you didn't socialize with her at college?
No.
And you didn't socialize with her outside of Atlas?
But you went drinking with her?
at all.
Um...
No, no, not at all.
Oh my god!
6 p.m.
So Simon did know Kate at college, but why would he lie
about that?
Maybe he knows Kate better than he's willing to admit.
Six o'clock.
I wonder if Rebecca's working in the pub tonight.
Ah, okay.
I'm gonna eat some goldfish.
Sorry, guys.
I got them extra cheesy goldfish.
They're so good.
They are the best kind, aren't they?
Okay, what do we got around here?
Oh.
Hmm?
A broken window recently smashed by the look of it.
Might have to ask about that.
Interesting.
Is that being held by washi tape?
What else is that?
Oh.
What did I just do?
Oh, broken pub window.
Okay, cool.
So we can enter the out building.
Ah!
No, no, no!
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, this has to be the key.
Yes.
Mm-hmm,
mm-hmm.
Yeah, this is pretty illegal.
Ugh.
What the hell?
I wonder whose mask this is.
Rebecca's or Ryan's?
They're doing sacrifices.
They're doing...
They're doing ritual sacrifices.
Oh no.
Oh no, I never thought we were so right!
What?
Oh no!
We're so...
Cult, cult, cult!
Just looks like junk, but it's too dark to tell.
Uh oh, we need a flashlight and come back, okay.
These look like giant leaks, don't they?
Everybody's cosplaying Hatsune Miku.
It's not a crime because he has a hat.
on if law and order has taught me anything likely they were
in an activist group together and one night he assaulted her
she recognized him and she was going to report him oh my
gosh wait why does that sound like a probability okay
let's get out of here before we're caught I wonder if
they're gonna be like how do you know about this mask don't
worry about it
Not sure if it's technically B&E, but it's at least
trespassing.
You know what?
That's fair.
Press the bell.
Ding-o-ling-ling.
No, let's go to the restaurant first.
Oh.
Nothing here.
There's a lot of ghostly voices happening for nobody in this
area.
Hmm.
Curious.
nothing to report sorry what can i get you detective
inspector jenks rebecca is it rebecca there's been an
incident in the village i'm conducting an investigation
could ask you a few questions please right come through
thank you she's so pretty is she a single haunted pub that's
a device there's been an unexplained death locally not sure
if you've heard The student?
Yes.
Yeah, so it's dreadful news.
You're married to Ryan, one of the Atlas leaders, yes?
I'm sorry, this place is small enough that everybody knows
everybody and all I mean.
Well, I just wanted to ask a few questions about Kate and
Atlas, if that's okay.
I don't know if I'll be able to answer any of them, but
sure.
Ibu Locksmith here.
That silver key, Yale key, literally can't go into that
master padlock.
Just one of those things you notice because of profession.
That's amazing.
Thank you for your insight.
Ghostly voices.
Minto Jenks might have some questions for you.
Did you know Kate?
Not very well.
She came in a few times, but she was quite a moody person.
You could tell she had problems.
Was she about to call in?
When was the last time you saw her?
Something not very nice.
Friday.
She popped in for a minute.
And when was that?
Seven-ish.
Was she on her own?
I didn't see who she was with.
She put 20 on the bar and then left.
What was that for?
A breakage, presumably.
20?
Just for a beer glass?
Well, she was very drunk.
She just put it on the bar and then walked out.
Was there a broken glass?
Not that I noticed.
But she was a strange girl.
Okay.
Give Rebecca 20 pounds for a breakage.
Was it the window?
Was it the window that she accidentally broke?
Huh.
Have you seen this before?
What do you plan?
So you didn't know if Kate had lost it.
Oh, so you're not checking her ID to make sure she's of
legal age to drink?
Okay.
Wow, that's suspicious.
That's suspicious, too.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, you didn't card her?
Actually, do they...
I know that the age of drinking is lower in Britain, too,
right?
So...
Do they card ever?
18.
It's more lax there.
Oh.
My ID doesn't get checked.
I'm thinking with my tiny world experience.
Simon's homebrew.
Yeah, do you know about this?
Know anything about Simon Thompson's homebrew?
Because he makes homebrew.
Apparently.
No, we do buy from a microbrewery, but we don't usually buy
from kitchen breweries.
Why?
about it does she buy simon's homebrew clearly not huh um
yeah do you know about this do you recognize this i've seen
students wearing them has some sort of meaning doesn't it i
forget what it is now i've seen anyone wearing one recently
not that i can remember okay okay your window is broken how
did the window get broken out around the back I don't
actually know someone said two girls were arguing outside I
found out after they'd gone and when was this?
last Friday just after we opened about half past six I'll
take over it until I can get it fixed we don't want people
getting cut and sealing us does that sort of thing happen a
lot?
no not really there's only two girls in town I don't think
are um suitable okay last friday approximately 6 30.
when did she come in did it say
come on is she stupid kate came to the pub around seven your
window was oh my god how did you not put two and two
together.
Also, you have a very suspicious creepy mask in there that I
found outside the pub and not in a storage that was
padlocked.
Do you know what this is?
Oh, you'll have to ask Ryan about that.
So this is Ryan's.
It's to do with one of Ryan's methods on the course.
Well...
Go on.
Masks allow you to play it being someone different for a
while.
Students find it quite liberating.
So this would be for a student.
I think that one's Ryan's, but students do wear them, yes.
And the creepy symbols on the top?
The creepy symbols...
We know why Rebecca isn't a detective.
Yeah.
Very, very interesting.
I'm gonna I'm gonna try and do this seven maybe I don't know
it's not a contradiction but it is a connection no okay
thank you probably be back later anyone at the restaurant
now nope okay just a little peek just a little all right we
can leave how do we find Ryan now
Um...
Hmm.
Actually, I'm gonna go ask...
We're gonna go ask Emma about the, uh...
About the window.
Let's see if she knows anything.
Oh, Emma!
Emma!
Just a few more questions if you don't mind.
Yeah, Jake says I asked Emma about the...
The stinking window.
Know anything about a broken window at the pub around the
back?
pub um a broken window at the back yeah i thought it was
broken when was that i was in the pub on monday with a
college friend
do pups have wine yeah when you broke it they do i'm gonna
i'm gonna say it's a contradiction we're gonna try it
doesn't like beer but was at the
See if it works.
Ah, ha!
Okay, never mind.
Monday before last Friday?
Yeah, right?
Some serve food and have accommodations.
Wow!
She's using the solid snake method.
Do not trust!
Do you know anything about this?
Ever seen this before.
Ever seen this?
before.
Nope.
I haven't.
I think I'd have remembered it.
Uh-huh.
Well, we can go ask Simon about it.
Pubs are more of social clubs than just a bar.
Oh, okay.
Pubs in the UK are just like Izakaya.
Oh.
Fun.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Simon!
Simon, let me back in.
Do you know anything about the pro- Do you know anything
about a broken window at the pub?
No, I don't really go to the pub very often.
I'm not exactly a pub person.
Claims he hardly ever visits the pub.
What about this?
Have a look at this.
Know anything about that?
I love Janks.
He's so funny.
He's so unserious.
I haven't seen this one.
But it looks a lot like an Atlas mask.
We use them for some of the workshops and stuff.
Really?
How?
Well, you have to say something boastful or arrogant.
You do it first without the mask and then you say it with a
mask.
And the point is?
Well, it's easier when you have the mask on, isn't it?
People are not as afraid to be free about themselves, you
know?
How did you find out about Atlas?
Well, it was advertised.
Actually, I think I've still got the...
This is the advert that was at my college.
The house is so cutely decorated.
To be honest, I've learned more in three months at Atlas
than I did in three years at business school.
Can I keep that?
Yeah, go for it.
Surely.
That's like when people say that they learn from TikTok.
This is useful as a conversational starter.
Simon gave Jenks the poster.
Atlas, life skills training.
The only thing limiting your future is your past.
The Atlas three-month intensive training course offers you
the chance to learn practical, effective, and highly sought
after real-world business skills recognized by some of the
largest companies and industries in the world easily the
best business course I've ever taken said Atlas student
Simon Lucas is this guy's name Simon Lucas Jenks wakes up
and decides to LARP as a cartoon detective is this guy's
last name Lucas book your place now I'll call this number
for your free brochure or visit atlas business training dot
call Thompson okay that'd be so funny okay be back later on
if that's okay let's see if maybe we can get to Atlas now
it's so funky though because it oh sorry I keep pressing
this as the map it says Paul and Ryan right here but we
don't get to maybe maybe let me try going back hello i'm i'm
once again entering your home no one's here all right let's
go to atlas oh it's open it's open awesome
park view into the atrium ryan was interviewed in the lounge
according to the report that must be his office okay the
reading room before we go to ryan though let's check
somewhere else let's just snoop around a little bit first
before you know okay this is the reading room with two
chairs facing the wall and blackout curtains and why can't i
see anything outside what are these chairs It doesn't seem
very comfortable.
The reading room.
Hmm.
You don't read when facing the wall?
I don't read.
I can't.
Anyway.
The lounge door.
Hello.
No!
Um.
Is there anything we can use?
Slip it under his door.
Slip this under his door.
He'll be like, how'd you find my mask?
Who, how'd you get this?
There's like a mirror.
The decorating is quite interesting.
No way, we can go to Alice and we can't do anything.
Again?
Please.
As an avid reader, I can confirm that we do often face the
wall.
Wow.
Very interesting.
Okay, well.
Let's leave, hun.
I wonder if there were any contradictions.
Meanwhile, she is literally reading everything in the game.
Can anyone spot the contradiction?
No, no, no.
Believe me, believe me.
hint better investigate the woods again oh should also call
the chief okay I was thinking about that also have things I
haven't asked Emma and Rebecca about oh it's probably ooh
this bad boy we haven't asked about okay look I guess we're
going back into the woods for some reason the clearing has
hmm what if what if there's like a animal that'd be exciting
it's so peaceful though okay yeah was there something I met
oh oh who are you who is it I'm a police officer detective
inspector Jenks it's all right you can carry on if you want
to I'm just going I'm investigating a death in the village
k9 there was a death recently and you are well could i ask
you a few questions please david thank you well if you give
me your name and address i'll come later on walks it he
walks it and what's your name
walks into the woods it.
Okay.
That was fun.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what was the last thing it said?
Oh, yeah, let's go ask Emma real quick about the poster.
Emma, I'm climbing through your window.
We don't even need to knock this time.
We just open it up and start crawling in.
Okay, that's what we say.
And I have a few more questions as I'm like...
As I'm just crawling through the window.
What do you know about Atlas?
Atlas.
I know that it's a business course.
I went with Simon when he first went, but it wasn't really
my thing.
How often did you go?
Just the once.
And you decided it wasn't for you?
Yeah, I'd been to something similar, so decided it wasn't
for me.
similar okay that's it for now thank you that reminds me of
when my friend once was like she was like I have a I'm going
to this I signed up for this business opportunity place you
need a job right Minto you should come with me and try the
orientation or like the the welcome you know like a the
introduction meeting oh Oh no.
Yeah, it was 100% in MLM.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, it was an MLM.
Yeah, it was a it was a it was definitely a pyramid scheme.
And my friend didn't know a melem.
That was a melem.
But my mom, like, I was about to say she loved loves MLMs.
No, she doesn't.
She like, my mom likes to know about scams.
And so when I told her, I was like, I went to go to this,
this, uh, meeting about this business thing.
And my mom knew the name immediately.
And she was like, no, tell your friend to quit.
Get out of there while you still can.
Yeah.
Coffee Zilla got her.
No!
Minto layered marketing.
Marketing.
Did I say that right?
Wait, marketing.
Marketing.
Yeah.
Oh, scary.
Rebecca, what do you know about Atlas?
Doesn't seem like... I don't think Atlas is this...
Is it MLM though?
I think Atlas is a cult and they sacrificed Rebecca.
Ding-a-ling-ing?
Ding-a-ling-ing.
Ding-a-ling.
What do you know about this?
How about there?
It's an advertisement.
They had it designed by an agency, I think.
And when was that?
Last year sometime.
What?
How do you know that?
Ryan had the poster designed by an agency.
The poster was designed last year.
What?
If I ran a self-help cult, what do you think your rules...
Oh, if I ran a self-help cult, what do you think your rules
would be?
Hmm.
Oh, she's married to Ryan.
That's right.
I forgot.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Um, my rules.
Can't be a bow and a lamb on a cult?
It could be.
Um, my rules.
My life, my rules.
My attitude.
It would be.
be don't go out at night
always be lemon stay in the light no oh she heading you know
I saw like a thing recently a video about oh she's got a
she's got it which is you know when you're when you are to
cut it that means you are tired oh she means that you are
getting fatigue of your Oshi, which, which I think, you
know, if you are very passionate about something and you,
you know, it can happen, maybe.
I don't know, I've never felt the fatigue of my Oshi before.
I don't know.
That sounds made up.
Apparently, it's like a buzz, not a buzzword, but like a,
it's been kind of catching more popularity than like
Japanese...
Twitter and stuff.
And, uh, I think, like, yeah, trending, trending, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so it's, it's like a, I guess a burnout when you're
just like, you, I mean, anybody would feel burnout, I feel,
if they are going, going, going with like a hobby or
something, but I would hope that, you know, for, I think in
my case, I, I would hope that you if you're like ah yeah i
feel i'm like i'm always trying to catch minto streams i'm
always trying to do this and that i would hope that you know
just just go at your own pace you know you don't have to
you're not you're not a bad fan if you miss one stream two
streams five streams ten streams you know like i want to be
just kind of like a source of entertainment kind of like a
tv show that you put on or something you know so don't worry
so much about about trying to be like the ultimate super fan
or anything i love how passionate you guys are don't get me
wrong i think that's my favorite thing about you guys but
you know just uh just make sure you're you know you're
you're taking care of yourself too so yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so you don't have the of Vito.
Thank you!
I don't believe it.
I'm always loving Vito 110%.
Thank you!
Thank you, but you're never a chore.
Almost a year, but don't fatigue for me.
Thank you!
Yeah, I want you guys to...
Like I said, you know, you...
If it helps to think...
I know sometimes people kind of put VTubers in their own
category a little bit, but...
I have like a regular streamer that I watch every day,
almost.
Sometimes he plays games and I'm like, I don't care so much
about this.
But if I think it's like, if I just kind of treat him as
like a TV show that I put on, then it's like not so, I don't
know.
You know, I don't feel like I have to watch every day.
I just kind of watch when I can.
Who?
His name's Incib.
Wait, Garthamaldi!
He plays a bunch of horror games, so I like to watch the
horror games.
I like to watch the horror games.
I have, like, him, and then I watch this other...
He doesn't stream that I know of, but his name is CJU Games.
He's, like, he's, like, my favorite, like, one of my
favorite, like, let's players of the indie, like, horror
games.
game variety and he doesn't have very many but he does
actually though that's a lie he has a lot of subscribers
like he has over 100k but he recently got to 100k and but
he's so good he's like one of those types that like doesn't
scream and doesn't do like the crazy reactions or anything
like that so like i can really just have him easily on in
the background and i'm like yeah this is this is nice
Oh my gosh!
I'd like to comment on his stuff to be like, put him in the
algorithm.
Just like hope that he gets more viewers.
Because his playthroughs are always so fun.
Yeah.
Not with this account though.
I have like a, I have a account.
Like a YouTube account that I have just for watching like
horror videos.
Because the thumbnails sometimes can be scary.
And if they pop up in my regular algorithm.
scared so I so I have the secret account just for for my
spooky games is it okay if I only watch you when lilac isn't
streaming why would you admit something like that though
that hurts my feelings I'm just kidding I'm just getting I'm
just kidding yeah of course thank you guys for those super
chats by the way i was like talking so if anything
supporting a check for me to is what gives me energy never
wears me out thank you i'm tired of me though let me watch
made mint instead no way i could have me too fatigue thank
you the most i've had to pace my oshikatsu when it involves
my wallet that's that's huge though like for real like i
think you know don't feel like you always have to super chat
you know don't feel like you have to send a don't know or
anything and like if you're like I gotta get every merch
drop or whatever like don't you know always prioritize
yourself first like sure I'll especially now that I'm with
like Den Setsu there will be more merch drops and stuff
actually I saw the merch the I think the merch for the jazz
show will be going up tomorrow but um Don't feel like
you're, you know, you can be like, I'm not super into this
thing.
You don't have to get it.
It's okay.
It's totally okay.
Yeah.
So.
Don't tell me what to do.
I'm sick of being phantom.
I'm going to watch me into phantom.
Saying that just makes me want to super tell you more.
No, I'm mean at all.
Loyalty to the end.
And Draygos, thank you.
Oh, Andrea goes, you sent some gifted before the stream
started.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But, yeah, I don't know.
I just want you guys to take care of yourselves.
And I would feel more sad if you felt like you were being
burnt out from watching me.
You know, I would feel so sad if it was just like, ah, I
just, I just can't keep up.
You know, like, that's okay.
That's okay.
I repeat the same stories all the time.
Don't worry about it.
Even if you're like, I'm not into this game.
That's okay.
I won't catch this stream because I'm not into this game.
That's all right.
Signed up to get Corgi Puppy in March.
Waiting for them to be bored.
Any name suggestions?
Also, definitely be financially responsible.
Yes.
Name suggestions Minto
Minto Minto?
Minto?
What are we doing here?
Sorry, I got lost chat.
There's a farm marked on the map.
Wonder where they grow there.
We are at the farm.
No?
That's what I clicked on.
Oh my gosh, I keep clicking the wrong thing.
I didn't click the wrong thing here, though.
This is the farm.
Oh, maybe I can get to the farm from here.
Maybe it's like a...
According to the map, Ivy Farm is across the road there.
Okay, okay, okay.
But then my Oshi will possibly say my name.
I just got paid so I can't send...
So I...
Wait.
I just got paid so I can't send a few supers.
That's okay.
Wait.
You can't?
That's okay.
Oh my gosh!
I just wanted to comment, but now...
Thank you so much for the...
Guys, I hope all.
I think it's the feeling of aging out or feeling stuck in
life.
A lot of otakus who turn 40 don't want to be the old, creepy
guy surrounded by younger fans.
It's okay why I wish I was married and had a kid to enjoy
stuff with.
I'm only in my late 20s.
Also, GF.
wife jealousy.
You think so?
Hmm.
Maybe.
I think, though, I would like to be somebody that could be
enjoyed by anybody, you know.
Also, hobbies.
And your interests, you know, hobbies don't have an age
limit.
So don't ever feel like, like if you grow out of, if you
lose interest in something, that's one thing.
But if you enjoy a hobby, don't deprive yourself of your
enjoyment because you think that it will be looked down
upon.
You know what I mean?
Just enjoy what you like.
They'll be so much happier that way.
why would you why would you want to be unhappy because of
the judgment of other people just enjoy what you like and
and then if you enjoy what you like and other people follow
suit as well you can find other people that are in your you
know same age range that also stuck around so don't worry
about it.
Oh my gosh, Mel, thank you!
Oh, get loved, appreciated, nerd, and also, I'm Boos!
You're all cute as heck!
Yeah, you guys are!
I'm in my early 40s and having a blast!
Let's go!
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah!
Yippee!
Okay, let's call the chief.
Okay, back to game.
Sorry.
I'm getting off my...
My...
I mean, I can.
Okay.
Fallen, thank you.
Chief.
You sound so...
She saw Kate in the pub last Friday, around 7, I think.
So she came in drunk, gave us some money for a breakage or
something, then left.
Well, she just came in and then went to...
strays out again what did she break i don't know rebecca
didn't know either or so she said doesn't sound right does
it i mean that that money must have been for something let's
rebecca make a few suggestions see if she bites simple
that's what i tried okay thanks chief okay thanks chief i
try to keep myself keep from burning out by always
prioritizing personal relationships i catch streams when i
can but not at the expense of spending time with people i
can always watch
I wish I got to watch enough bit to get fatigued, but I got
time right now.
Yippee.
Yippee!
Thank you!
Let's head to the farm.
I boost Qtasagmito chat reflects the streamer.
So true.
What's up the steps?
Wait.
Not me.
Maybe, man.
35 having a great time.
Yippee!
What are these?
Don't just slam it back in.
Picture frames with black painted glass.
Very interesting.
He like picked it up and like threw it back down.
Study your art project.
Oh my gosh.
Once again, not breaking, but we are definitely entering.
Hit show black mirror.
Hit show black mirror
Oh, I thought it was a doorbell Oh my gosh, look at all the
spider Was that a spider?
Could I ask you a few more questions, please?
It didn't take you long Haven't got much time Didn't take
you long Well, I at least Let you get home, didn't I?
Where do you want to sit?
Oh, anyway, it's fine I didn't quite catch your name How
tall is he?
Sit there He's bending over in this house.
Why are you asking me about K-Py?
Routine.
Oh my gosh.
You know Simon, don't you?
Thompson.
Why, what did he say?
That you all went to college together, you and Kate.
Is that right?
Wait, what?
Might have done.
Right.
Good enough.
It's a hobbit hole.
Okay.
Let's start at the very beginning.
James.
I don't remember James.
When was the last time you saw Kate Vine?
Can't remember.
How did you know her?
Through Simon, his girlfriend was mates with her.
Saw around college a few times.
Did you socialize with her much?
Nah.
She wasn't my type.
Okay.
Why is he kind of creeping me out?
James, you're kind of scary.
Why are you kind of...
She wasn't my type.
Did you know whether Kate had lost this or not?
No idea.
Doesn't know if Kate had lost the license.
Uh...
Are you gonna go steal the bicycle?
Do you want to do a crime together?
What do you know about Simon's bike?
Stream time is weightlifting time.
Let's go.
You haven't seen him on a bike?
I haven't seen him.
When was the last time you saw him?
About a month ago.
Why is he so suspicious?
He's not creepy, just a hobbit otaku.
Uh, uh, the homebrew.
Does, do you know about the, have you seen the screwdriver?
Have you, uh, ever tried Simon's homebrew?
Thompson's tar, yeah, I've tried it.
Thompson's tar.
To me, not for money anyway.
We used to trade stuff.
Oh wait, is this the guy he traded the herbs with?
Make a nice herbal tea, is it?
Yeah.
friend we're into it what was this beer like lethal strong
look your eyes out interesting the herbs wait herbs and
quote oh a weed 37 are watching Vito at two in the morning
Saturdays can be exciting go to sleep do you know about the
freedom ever seen one of these before freedom necklace I
don't think so Skye's giving us the most minimal answers
ever know anything about a broken window at the pub don't go
to the pub you've never been to the pub didn't say that I've
been to the pub but not about two months three months okay I
haven't been to the pub for over two months all right do you
what would you do of this thing ever seen this before no
should I have no it's okay all right we're just going
through the whole thing ever seen one of these seen them
around college what do you know about it not much it's a
business course that's Simon he's on it you wouldn't be
interested in that sort of thing and you haven't not really
business doesn't interest me does anything interest you this
guy okay I know Jenks is so goofy I love him herbs probably
herbs herbs what's all this stuff in the workshop paint and
stencils and things like that forgive a guy a little
sideline yeah a hobby oh you do picture framing they're
black Scrying mirrors!
Now what's a scrying mirror?
He likes girls!
Scrying goes back centuries.
The ancient Persians did it.
This country pagans still practice it.
The fortune tellers pretend to do it.
That's what the crystal ball's all about.
And the druids?
It's all scrying.
But what is scrying?
Depends who you are.
People do it for different reasons.
what sort of reasons that didn't answer anything what is
scrying I don't know people do it yeah that's me is that
what you use them for James communicating with the dead how
they make them for other people these days and there's a
market for these is there lots of people want to talk to the
dead even if they don't believe in it I'm scrying I'm
scrying you guys are scrying I'm very charitable of you can
I keep this keep it Thank you.
I like our...
Mirrors and hookah pipes.
Hookah pipes.
I wonder what else James is into.
Interesting.
I like how the scrying mirrors are just like spray painted
frames in the backyard.
I'm shaking and scrying.
You guys are scrying right now?
Usually I communicate through a spirit box, but Maybe I
should try, I've never tried a scrying mirror before.
That's so exciting.
Excited for the Mint Phantom Black Mirror merch where she
talks to you?
It'll be like one of those like Halloween ones where you
press a button and my reflection shows up or something.
Wait.
Wait, that's kind of a good idea actually.
Memo.
mirror to merch list actually let me wait that'd be so cool
though i sent some other like merch ideas to steiner manne
the other day and i was like um i don't know how feasible
these are they just come to my brain sometimes um i just
wanted to ask if it's possible ever and he was like he was
like always ask even if it's he's so tsundere he says that
he's gonna quit Or that he's gonna like...
That he's gonna...
He wants to be fired, he wants to like quit.
But then...
But then when I say like, oh I have a stupid merch idea,
he's just like, oh yeah, tell me anytime you have an idea,
no matter how dumb, we'll always try to do it for you guys.
So tsundere!
We're seeing a cute ghost in the lower left of our scrying
mirrors right now.
Actually, yeah, yeah.
In the stream, straight up scrying it.
Cendere of Denzetsu.
For real!
Phoebe was like trying to do something the other day.
And he was just like, I'm going to quit.
I'm going to quit.
He's so cendere.
Thank you.
Oh, wait.
Did I have anything else?
No, I think that was it.
So dramatic.
All right.
Let's see.
Now we have this very exciting mirror to show off to
everybody.
Do you scry?
Do you scry at night?
Otaku's favorite anime is Eskri!
I haven't...
I...
I have not thought of that show in...
Give me more questions, please.
In...
Million years.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, bro.
Have you seen one of these before?
Is it meant to be black like that?
I think so.
No.
Has never seen the Black Mirror TV show on Netflix before.
Never finished it?
Me neither.
I don't think I finished it either.
I don't even remember what it's about.
You go to actually when they scry.
all right i think our friend simon probably knows about this
mirror okay emma i'm going through your window i'll ask you
a couple more things please
have you seen one of these before is that from james now
what do you know about james that is creepy oh he was
selling them last friday at the market there's a market
every week type thing like a flea market and uh i usually go
there for lunch so you wouldn't buy one of these no i
wouldn't but kate would was she uh into this sort of thing
no i i don't think so she bought one and uh i went around to
her flat to try it out oh you're meant to see ghosts or
spirits or something it doesn't work how do you use it
you're just meant to stare into it oh Why does she look so
funny?
Shall I show you?
Oh, okay.
Okay, so you just...
You just stare like this.
And...
Oh, my gosh, you're going to see Kate?
Then you see...
Kate.
See what?
Sorry.
Um...
Look, you're meant to see a ghost or something.
look it doesn't work wait is this getting kind of spooky
says
the mirror doesn't work I see I see I see be back later on
if that's okay very yeah she was oddly into it right huh huh
ever seen one of these audio in this room in particular is
terrible.
He's into a dead of night.
Same team.
Mysticism, magic spells, that sort of thing.
He's nuts though.
I mean, he thinks the government are tracking him or
something.
Why would he think that?
I don't know.
You'd have to ask him.
They're seeing him through the mirror, the scrying mirror.
Oh no!
James thinks the government is tracking him.
They're tracking him through the scrying mirror.
I'll probably be back later.
Let's go try Atlas again.
There we go.
They're scrying on him.
Yeah, they're scrying on him.
It's random.
Oh.
Oh, I thought this was a new...
Anybody in here?
Anybody reading in the reading room?
Shut.
Nobody's reading in the reading room.
Anybody scrying in the reading room?
room anybody crying in the reading room let me in okay dang
let's try this building where we found the let's try the
this one the mirror shows your browser history whoa no oh no
hmm I feel like we need that we have a probably a call
There's a contradiction somewhere.
What did we talk with the chief about?
I don't remember.
Behind the house.
Yeah, let's see if there's anything here now.
Oh, the window!
That's right!
That's right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So let's go back to Rebecca and push her a little bit more
about the window.
Show her the mirror?
We did!
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
Yeah, okay.
So let's go through.
Let's see, has never seen the black mirror before?
Suggest talking to Ryan about the mask.
Doesn't know who broke the window.
Heard an argument between two girls outside.
Rebecca doesn't know who was arguing or who broke the window
outside last Friday.
I wonder if it's connected with this breakage.
Ah!
I got it, first try!
So, you said Kate gave you 20 for a breakage, but you
didn't have a breakage.
That's right.
Do you think the payment could have been for the broken
window?
Could it have been Kate who was arguing?
Well, I suppose it could have been.
Yeah.
It could have been Kate.
You're probably right, yeah.
But you don't know who she was arguing with?
No, I'm not sure.
I'll ask around.
the window.
Rebecca really should have worked that out before now,
unless she did.
But why would she lie about that?
Rebecca told Jenks about the argument in the pub last
Friday.
Oh, Kate's argument, okay.
Yeah.
Huh.
I know.
Thank you.
No, the insult here is the 20 pounds for the broken window.
Like, that's crazy.
All right, let's go talk to Emma.
Emma, I'm climbing through your window.
Actually, I'm gonna break her window and be like, Ever seen
one of these?
Does this remind you of anything?
More questions if you don't mind.
Did you hear about an argument in the pub last Friday?
No, I wasn't there.
You weren't in the village?
No, I went home last Thursday night, actually, to see my
parents.
But you do visit the pub.
Oh, yeah, I mean, I know Rebecca quite well.
We all went there.
Quite a bit after college.
Uh-huh.
Went home to see... Wait.
Uh...
Suss.
Yeah, objection?
Objection?
I'm just trying to see where.
Uh, hold on.
Okay.
She went home to her parents on Thursday.
Maybe?
Wasn't she at the market on Friday?
Oh, did she say that?
Wait.
Ah!
Dun, dun, dun!
You're right.
Aha.
So, you went home to see your parents on Thursday night.
That right?
Yes.
But you said you saw James at the market on Friday.
Um, no, I went to, um, I went to see my parents on Friday.
Friday night what time did you go on Friday um eight or nine
and you didn't see Kate at all on Friday no you're not a
very good liar Emma okay I saw Kate where that's the day she
died isn't it ah what were you arguing about I I'd lent her
50 pounds because she was desperate and we were just arguing
I didn't bother me she just didn't have it and kate broke
the window you broke the window she she did things like that
but she was angry smash things yes so it was emma arguing
with kate but why didn't she want to admit it in case it
gave her a motive or something else yeah something else lent
money to kate because kate needed it went home to see
parents thursday night oh wait we know this is not true
anymore yeah okay it's like it's blacked out now she was
there last cuter dune friday whoops saturday
kudur dune thursday whoops right suddenly it's friday
she didn't have 50 but she gave away 20 for a window right
that's what i was thinking too so let's try that i must said
she lent money to kate for to kate because kate was
desperate for cash Wait, it's under...
Oh my gosh, this is the hardest part, is finding where the
prompts are.
Uh...
Where would it be under?
It's not under broken pub window.
Um...
I'm just clicking on anything now.
Ha!
I don't know.
Wait.
Hmm.
She knew nothing about the 20.
Well, that's, I guess it's true, right?
Sure, your attorney's pin.
Wait, wrong game.
It did, yeah, she did buy a lot of jewelry.
So, let's see if it's that.
Oh, good job, guys.
So you lent money to Kate because she was desperate but she
bought loads of jewelry and things so why were you lending
her money well no it's because um because I'm what spit it
out it was it wasn't about money was it Emma no go on what
was it really about we were arguing because she was going to
blackmail Ryan the guy from Atlas over an affair was having
and then tell his wife if he didn't give her the money
Ryan's affair with Kate no I don't know I think he was
having an affair with another student and Kate found out and
why were you involved because I didn't really agree with it
I didn't agree with what she was doing even if he did have
an affair were you friends with Ryan no I'd never met him
you just thought Kate was wrong uh-huh I don't know not sure
about this Emma's either on a moral crusade or there's
another reason she was worried Ryan right um that doesn't
really has never met Ryan but she knows uh but she said
she's good friends with um uh she said she said she's good
friends with Rebecca hold on uh where was that under wait
had been to a similar oh no similar course just kidding um
wait no she went to Alice with Simon yeah you liar you said
you went to an Atlas meeting with Simon yes that's
interesting because I happen to know that Ryan is the main
lecturer at Atlas you say you never met him this face you
say you don't know him okay I need I need to tell you
something I just need to make sure Simon doesn't find she
had an affair she's the she's the mistress and you can't
tell rebecca either oh okay so the affair what happened was
was between ryan and i oh my god i was having the affair and
kate knew so kate was blackmailing both of you no she didn't
care about me it was part of the course you see having to
take all these risks she thought it was funny to turn her
back on ryan she thought i
yes i was already with simon when ryan and i you know and i
didn't want simon finding out and kate thought simon's ear
to the wall is the other room and then if rebecca found out
then simon would definitely have found out and then it would
have blown up and it would have just been a big mess so you
just argued and well you got yourself into the mess little
missy well she just stormed off from a burglar window.
And that was it.
You didn't see her again that night?
No.
Are you sure?
Yes.
I promise.
You like her hair?
It's very anime, isn't it?
Oh!
7pm!
Oh my gosh!
You just feel like the chapters.
So, Ryan's a bit of Lothario, is he?
What the Lothario?
I met this Ryan Rand face to face.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Oh, it's getting good.
It's getting juicy.
Oh, whoops.
This is the back of the pub, my bad.
I thought this was the back of the house.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
A cheater.
Let's see.
It was over here, no?
Yes.
I wonder if he's here or if he's at Atlas.
We'll go see.
Okay, let's go to Atlas.
Okay.
Nice work, detective.
You two, detective.
Detectives?
All right, Ryan.
If that's your real name, open up.
Ryan!
Oh my god!
Detective Inspector Jenks, I'm conducting an investigation
in the area.
When am I asking you a few questions?
Is that alright?
Come in, Inspector.
Thank you.
you can't okay i'm sorry but like if you are in a town with
five people you can't go cheating i mean cheating is bad
already but like you can't go cheating and then expect
nobody to find out there's five people in town i believe
that uh kate vine was a student at atlas kate vine well yes
she was all of this has been thoroughly investigated
inspector it was suicide well we have reason to believe
there may be rather more to it than that really oh then in
that case i'd be prepared to assist in any way possible
thank you pleasure
why is everyone in this town suspicious looking i know all
right let's start at the very beginning i believe the last
time you saw Kate Vine was at the pub last Friday then you
came straight back with some of the students is that right
yes I like to have a glass of port or two after a long day
and benefits of being married to the landlady how did she
seem that night the landlady Kate okay why is she saying it
like that yes I mean it didn't impair her ability though she
was a very bright star lots of potential very seem to be
enjoying the course as far as anybody could tell yes when
did you first meet her uh when she joined about three months
ago and you hadn't met her before then no so you didn't
suspect there was anything wrong well do you mean did i
expect her to drown herself of course i didn't inspect her
it was quite a shock nobody expected that uh-huh okay last
arcaded atlas meeting last Friday Kate was drunk first met
Kate three months ago at Atlas said Kate enjoyed the course
and appeared happy hadn't suspected she had any emotional
problems okay but we know she was a bit explosive before not
that I recall you don't know whether Kate had lost this or
not no I've never seen it before sorry I'm getting real
defensive mister why so angry why are you so upset about it
huh yeah i've never seen it before i don't know i don't know
i don't know what you're talking about uh why are we asking
about the bicycle again does simon thompson ride a bike do
you know i think so yes i think i think he drives as well
but i might be mistaken simon doesn't ride a or does ride a
bike thinks simon also drives but isn't sure why why is this
relative like relative i don't get it whatever that's fine
do you know anything about a screwdriver I've seen it.
And if you were to identify it, would you report it back to
the original owner that you saw it in my pocket?
The village bicycle.
Have you tried Simon's homebrew?
Does he make homebrew?
No, I haven't had the pleasure.
Okay, hasn't tried Simon's homebrew.
Broken pendant.
Yeah, the freedom.
No, this is.
Yes.
The music's so dramatic, but Jenks is so silly.
It's a symbol that we use on the course.
It's supposed to represent freedom from the chains of your
ancestry.
Have you ever bought one of these?
I haven't, but I've seen the students wearing them.
What if he bought the necklace for Emma?
Have we interviewed the bike yet?
Here it gets around.
some things right if he if it's used on the course why
wouldn't he have bought it before you know hmm curious very
very curious what do you know about the broken window at the
back of the pub no Rebecca told me about it I don't know how
it got smashed though I told her to tape over it we can't
have anybody cutting themselves you have to be very health
safety conscious these days health and safety conscious
health and safety conscious what the heck oh it's taught
wait no I want to save the mask for last because it's so
interesting about this ah it's uh it's first one we ever
have made we had it designed by an agency after we'd spent
weeks trying to trying to find a name this place.
It took you weeks.
Don't be like that, Inspector.
I thought it was a rather grand name.
Actually, if I'm being honest, I plucked it out of thin air
one night in the George while I was having a few gin and
tonics.
Well, actually, somebody left a book and I stole it.
This guy is so...
He basically just te he peddled at us.
Oh my god!
He's so cheeky!
Oh my gosh, have you ever tried a scrying mirror?
Have you seen one of these before?
believe that looks like a scrying mirror to me I have seen
one before hmm well I used to have one myself actually along
with lots of other bits and pieces of that nature silly
things you know really yes when I was in my teenage years I
had quite an obsession with that kind of thing I was a very
somber child and not that you could tell always playing
fantasy games reading books about that kind of malarkey you
know malarkey what sort of books did you read well books on
black magic not the chocolates satanic rituals that kind of
thing I grew out of it of course but you're not into that
sort of thing now of course I'm not I mean I don't need to
believe in the supernatural inspector the natural world is
far more interesting don't you think so oh and I don't don't
I don't believe this guy at all this guy is definitely doing
this guy is definitely doing crazy rituals I used to be an
otaku type situation I don't believe you one bit I don't
believe you one bit do you know anything about an argument
in the pub last Friday what time I believe it wasn't long
after the opened no I usually leave for the manor house
about six games too scary is it because it's British I like
to get a head start doesn't know about the argument usually
leaves Rylas at six starts preparations Rylas 630 okay all
right time for the mask I'm so excited can you tell me about
this haven't seen that for a while we had a friend who used
to make them for us for the course he passed away last year
what does the symbol mean yeah it's borrowed from paganism
it's the symbol of the triple goddess the mother maiden and
crone represented by the waxing and waning of the moon it's
an ancient symbol it predates Christianity some people say
that it dates back to Paleolithic times and is that relevant
to the course well no no no I mean it's a symbol we we've
dabbled with but it's it on the course, no.
I see.
The symbol is not used on the course.
Okay, time to look at everything, you guys.
Is this a symbol?
Atlas name picked randomly.
I thought he said he stole it.
But the mask is from the course.
This almost looks like the symbol.
Actually looks more like an eyeball, but whatever.
The triple goddesses.
Minto Phoebe and Victoria.
Praise the son!
I'm in a cult!
Blonde guy said it was part of the course.
The symbols or...
But he said the mask is used for the course, but not...
The symbol specifically, I don't think Simon brought up.
I feel like there's a contradiction, but I just don't know
where.
Used to have a black mirror himself.
Used to read about black magic and satanic rituals.
Doesn't believe in anything supernatural now.
Then why have the symbol?
Let's try it.
Nope.
If he left at 6.30, wouldn't he see the argument outright?
What?
Uh, but I don't think we have that.
Oh, wait, wait.
Uh.
Oh, it doesn't know how it got broken.
Yeah.
Wait, no.
Oh, well, it was our...
Let's see.
No, because if he starts preparations, I think they said
630, didn't they?
He didn't leave at 630.
He starts prepping at 630.
I feel like we have something, but I'm not quite sure.
Said he never bought a freedom necklace.
And some of these are like green.
Have you noticed that?
I wonder why.
Hmm.
Maybe that's like a hint or something.
I think those are usable items.
I don't think so.
green means objects oh okay so these are my notes this is an
object okay okay okay I get it okay yeah yeah yeah okay that
makes sense
hinto for minto no just trying to figure it out just going
through everything it was a lot of information so I'm
sussing out the bird in the cage thing, the necklace.
Simon writes his book.
I can't...
Hmm.
When all else fails, click randomly.
I don't think that works here.
I want to press more about the friend who died last year.
What is that about?
Was it something about Kate being there on Friday?
Uh, I don't think we have that in here or
Kate was drunk at the meeting I will let me try this it says
that she was drunk at the meeting but doesn't know about the
argument at the pub seems kind of no okay never mind because
it's just like oh she got drunk at the pub so you don't know
that she was arguing you know hmm hmm
first met Kate three months ago at Atlas but
saw students wearing the necklace the only necklace we've
seen that wearing it is Emma right but if he hold on no
we'll come back we'll come back thank you probably be back
later
I'm suspecting the bicycle.
Same?
Okay, I'm looking at the clue.
What the?
What's the exclamation point for?
Better see Simon again.
You also have some things you haven't asked Simon and James
about yet.
What was that?
What did he give us?
What did we not ask?
The argument?
Maybe?
Go talk to Simon.
I think the bike is our culprit.
Yeah, we should arrest the bike.
There you go.
Come on.
Thank you.
He got a cute little apron on.
Smells nice.
What is that?
Chili pork.
Oh, that sounds so yummy.
Used to be more into it.
No, I don't do it so much.
Used to grow my own herbs and everything.
Not here.
No.
At the farmhouse where I used to live.
Where was that?
That's where James lives.
Yeah, we used to share our house together.
The farmer used to let us use it.
a corner of his greenhouse to grow stuff interesting james
that well well didn't really get on yeah well it's just
through the farm yard at the back interesting uh-huh so the
argument what we did ask about yeah james is into new age
mysticism know anything about an argument at the pub that's
right No, I didn't go to the pub last Friday.
What did you do after the course?
Just went home.
Came here.
Just came straight back.
Why is it?
Oh, not his eyes darting.
Why is everybody lying to us?
I don't, I didn't do anything last Friday.
I came straight home.
I swear.
I honestly, I never saw Kate.
I never saw anybody.
I just, I didn't go to the pub or anything.
Wait, wait, isn't there that one game?
Like, what a game is it?
It's like another detective game, and they're like, I don't
know anything about it.
I, like, you, LA, don't worry.
You like, they're just like, I don't know anything about it,
officer.
Quit asking me.
It's so funny.
Minto did it.
Yeah, I did.
What did I do?
It's so...
They'll be so...
They make like this goofy, guilty face afterwards.
I've never heard that name before.
And I never will hear it again in my life.
I'm...
the when the ghost is sus doesn't know anything about the
argument went straight home okay let's see uh i
saw kate at the atlas meeting last friday so that kind of
checks because he said that he went straight home after
atlas doesn't know anything about the argument claims he
hardly ever visits the pub uh i'm i am going through things
uh doesn't see james very often he did say that they don't
really get along do happen in the fire screwdriver
okay i'm not seeing anything that like is jumping out at me
But they shared a greenhouse corner.
They must have a past.
Yes.
Let's go talk to James.
James will be honest with us.
James will surely know.
Oh, wait.
I keep going the wrong way, my bad.
Chief, I'm confused.
Chief, tell me something.
Talk to me, Chief.
I can't.
I can't tell if this is actually calling or not.
Okay, whatever.
Abbey Farm.
Hello.
Ringlinglingling.
Ringlingling.
Look at this.
Oh, did you guys see the spider?
A couple more questions if that's okay.
I forgot to show you guys again.
Kate's argument.
Do you know anything?
No, anything about an argument at the pub last Friday.
No.
Okay.
We came all the way across town for that.
No.
Okay, bye.
Be that later on, if that's okay.
What's my hint?
Did Simon say there was another greenhouse at Abbey Farm?
Did it?
Actually, I don't remember that at all.
Wait, can we go up?
Check it out.
Simon mentioned another greenhouse on the farm.
Oh.
Okay, I missed that.
Missed that point.
Oh my gosh, I need to pay attention.
I need to lock in.
I need to be, I need to be, I need to be jerking it around.
Is this, I'm, look at this little onsen.
Wow.
Okay, large greenhouse.
What we got going on in here?
Yeah, because we're detective jerkins.
Okay.
Is that a weed?
Is it?
Actually, I don't know.
I don't know.
I wonder if James knows this is here.
M.M.
It would be interesting to see what he says about it.
For marijuana marijuana?
Oh my god.
Packet of dried leaves.
M.M.
Flip it around.
Wicked Witch!
M-M.
Try using this!
I'm using the leaves.
A packet of suspicious looking leaves was found in the
greenhouse at the farm.
M-M.
Turn it around.
Flip it around.
Wicked Witch!
Why are you like this?
It's not me, the game!
did this the game did this I'm really enjoying this uh you
know how like in some movies when they film at the daytime
but they have to use a blue filter to make it look like it's
nighttime really enjoying that right now back down day for
night yeah oh there's the spider questions please thank you
what do you could you tell me what these are please I found
them in the greenhouse what are you doing in my greenhouse
he's snooping around on the farm have we it's called
investigating James yeah it's just mint mint leaves for
cookie yeah I I heard you were a bit of a budding chef
dabble a bit won a few competitions very impressive so you
normally just leave packets of mint lying around what's the
drunken it's I think this game is made for me.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I'm crying.
You did say you traded the herbal teas for...
Told you she did it.
Oh.
Want some cookery competitions.
Wait, hold on.
I've got to rewatch this again.
Could you tell me what These are, please.
I found them in the greenhouse.
But you're snooping around on the farm, have we?
It's called investigating, James.
It's just mint.
Mint leaves for cooking.
Yeah, I...
I heard you were a bit of a budding chef.
Dabble a bit.
One of few competitions.
Very impressive.
So you normally just leave packets of mint lying around.
Must have dropped it.
Where were you last Friday?
Okay, that's it for now.
Thank you.
Our little shoulder bag's getting quite heavy, probably.
All right, let's head back to Simon.
Ask him about this.
This mint.
I ask you a couple more things, please.
Know what these are?
A weed.
No.
look a bit like sage sleeves haven't seen them before though
no no no m m we don't have anyone that's emma emma could be
sage uh wait um
thank you probably be back later yeah it would smell like
mint if it were mint you know what these are by any chance
it's funny No.
Sorry.
I don't know anything about plants or things like that, but
you should ask Rebecca.
She used to live on a farm.
She'd know.
Why is she'd know?
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Didn't we say you traded for herbs?
Yeah, that's why I was trying to get that to kind of not do
the, like to kind of be like, hey, you should know you
traded for herbs, but it didn't have it as like a.
Maybe I looked under the wrong thing.
Well, we can go back.
Ding, ding, ding!
Just a few more questions if you don't mind.
Do you know what these are?
Ah, magic mint.
Where did you find this?
Where are we?
Magic mint.
Salvia divinorum.
I used to grow it years ago.
It makes you trip.
In what way?
It's a hallucinogenic.
And legal.
Oh.
Quite a dangerous combination.
Oh, wait.
Do you use it?
Me?
No.
No, I don't even take medicines.
I, um, I like to stay pure.
I didn't expect Rebecca to know about growing drugs.
No, she claims not to use them herself, but I'm not so sure.
Drugs!
It's a magic mint!
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
I'm, I'm, I, I am, I am, I'm normal.
I'm not a drug.
I'm not a drug!
I'm not!
The salvia!
What was it?
Salvia...
Something something.
I didn't know Magic Mike had a sequel.
Oh, I keep going the wrong way.
Here we go.
That's what...
M-M!
Magic Mint!
Look at the spider.
Right there.
Ask about a few more things, please.
Ever heard of salvia divinorum?
Divinorum?
It sounds like a...
What's that?
Skin cream.
It's not a skin cream, no.
A hallucinogenic me, though.
Really?
Don't know much about plants.
Oh.
So you've never heard of Salvia?
No.
You're such a liar.
How can I get...
I've never heard of Salvia.
If you're not a drug, then why do I get so giggly if I take
your stream?
Yeah, he says with the hooves.
in the background.
I know, right?
What the heck?
This guy.
Wait, how can we get him in his lie?
Um...
If you know they're...
Wait, let's see.
Really?
Okay, uh...
I mean, watching you is quite a trip, and that I trip over
you because you're below line of sight.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna fight you.
I'm gonna fight you.
I'm gonna fight
you.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, here's the traded herbal tea.
What doesn't know much about plants.
There we go, right?
What?
He would have to know about herbs to trade.
Wait.
Oh, come on.
Anklebiter.
Guys, come on.
We're solving a murder here.
I'm not going after any ankles.
Fight rhymes with height, so I don't think you'd be very
good at it.
Oh, fight rhymes with height.
Whose dog is this?
Don't change the subject.
The packet?
Want some cookery con- but he doesn't- Oh yeah, you'd have
to know about plans to win comp.
What?
You'd have to know about plants and herbs to win a cookery
competition, right?
You'd have to know what you're putting in.
Uh...
Hmm...
He knew it was mint.
Yeah!
Contains mint leaves.
Doesn't know about plants.
Oh.
Considering both your effect on us and your hue is magic
mint, you sound mighty sussy right now.
I'm a detective, I'm a detective.
He said it was ordinary mint, right.
Never heard, I'm just going to try it, never.
Because it's not called the magic mint.
I
don't think the order matters.
Magical girl mint.
Yeah, now we're talking.
Now we're talking.
I guess we could go ask other people.
Let's just go ask other people, I suppose.
Hello, hello, Emma.
Do you know what Wasalia is?
You can still solve crime as a gumshoe, even if for you,
It's more like a gum boat.
What does that even mean?
Ever heard of Salvia Divinorum?
Divinorum.
Yeah, yeah, I've heard of it.
Oh, you have?
Yeah.
A hallucinogenic drug.
Ever tried it?
Oh my God, is that?
No, I've never taken any illegal substances.
Never taken illegal substances.
Okay.
Why do I feel like she said something that she had before?
It's lit.
Yeah, did it do...
the other Rebecca said it was legal later he's like Jim
Carey he really has like that effect ever heard of salvia
divinorum salvia divinorum yeah magic mint same thing oh
yeah you mean the drug and yeah yeah flip it around did we
but I once or twice yeah oh but it's not really my sort of
thing it messes with your brain I've never tried any other
drugs either one nothing like that nothing hallucinogenic
Never tried any other hallucinogenic drugs.
Has tried Salvia a few times.
Remember, we would have favors.
Good luck.
Wicked Wint.
Magic mint to wicked wint.
There is no lilac, there's only wicked wint.
Something's not right.
You think so?
I don't think so, so far.
Uh.
No, I don't think so, so far.
Hmm.
Well.
Hasn't seen the leads before, but he said, wait, if he's
tried it before, then maybe?
No, okay.
Hmm.
That's it for the time being, thank you.
That didn't work though.
Let's try Atlas.
Yeah, my jacket.
I'm cold now.
I'm putting my jacket back on.
I'm cold.
How old is this game?
Keep the Ectoplasm warm.
I'm like, no, I'm like kind of, I'm kind of like shrimpin'
because I'm getting cold.
Sold beer to James, but doesn't get along with him.
A few more questions, please.
Have you ever heard of Salvia Divinorum?
No.
What is it?
It's a hallucinogenic plant.
A legal one.
At least for the moment.
Is it still legal?
2014, 2015?
My job.
That's the only drug I need.
As trite as that may sound.
Do you know any students who may have used Toast Nidgins?
No, no, my students aren't interested in that kind of thing.
Besides, no one is allowed drugs or alcohol onto the site.
I don't think anyone has ever brought drugs to Atlas.
Do you have any medicines on site at all?
No, we're not allowed insurance purposes.
Uh-huh.
Doesn't keep medicines on site.
Doesn't allow drugs or alcohol on Atlas premises.
But...
I mean, Kate was drunk at the last meeting.
Well, I guess it doesn't mean she brought it, but hold on,
let me just try it.
No, okay.
Isn't he drinking?
I know, right?
What the heck?
He's drinking right now.
Unfortunately, that is not a thing that is not in our
evidence.
Okay, thank you.
Probably be back later.
Yeah, like something like an EpiPen, or like, you could keep
like a Tylenol, like just some sort of ibuprofen, something
on...
Seems like you should.
I don't know.
I guess you don't have to.
Let's go ask Simon about not getting along with James, but
he does sell beer.
I don't think he still does.
We'll try it, though.
Selling it, but only sold to James.
Uh...
Wait, do we not have...
Maybe we don't have a thing that says...
He doesn't... Oh, doesn't see James very often.
No, I don't think we have one that says that he doesn't like
James.
Yeah, I don't think so.
Never mind.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Oh, hint.
Hint.
Show tip, please.
Better try the woods again!
Ryan about the packet of leaves.
Oh, I forgot.
Thank you, Gim.
The game is so good at being like, oh, by the way, I guess
when I've truly run out of, like, things,
I just go back to the woods.
I just gotta start walking around.
A few more questions, if you don't mind.
These hints are sassy.
You're like, I was like, you didn't ask it.
Do you know what this is?
M-M.
Looks like chopped tea bags.
me what is it i just thought you might know i don't know
anything about plants inspector what you should do is ask
rebecca she knows far more about these things than i do
messy things growing things why is he so strange about it
why is he so strange doesn't know anything about plants okay
be back later on if that's okay let's go to the woods to the
woods to the woods to the woods woods woods to the woods to
the woods to the woods to the woods to the woods to the
woods to the woods to the woods to the woods to the woods to
the woods woods into the woods into the woods into the woods
into the clearing oh what's happening do you mind not
defacing public property please what's it to you oh well I'm
a policeman and that's supposed to make what difference
exactly.
It means that you do exactly what I tell you to do.
Or what?
Or you arrest me?
Now I'll give you a fine this time.
So if I do something that you don't like, I have to give you
some money.
What happens if you do something that I don't like?
You're going to give me some money?
Look, I do not have time to discuss it at the moment.
Can you just go?
Who is this guy?
Oh my god.
Pathetic.
No.
What did he even write?
That's actually pretty clean for like a carving on a tree.
What a prize brat.
But why would he carve that into a tree?
Well, he's a diehard rock fan or there's more to that symbol
than meets the eye.
That's the symbol for love.
That's love.
No, the one with your thumb in.
is the horns but the one with your thumb out is a love not
very rock and what if he just got it wrong what if he
thought he was doing the the rock and roll but he did love
instead because he's silly are we just gonna go ask
everybody about this now all right time this game is so
funny hello do you know anything about this symbol anything
about the symbol go yeah spider-man what if he's a big more
questions if you don't mind spider-man fan if I did this
would that mean anything to you it's a devil sign isn't it
no is that what you're getting at inspector this is not
something you use on the course it's not something we use on
the course inspector i don't even know what that could
possibly mean exactly thinks the fingers is a devil sign
okay that's no he's wrong guys i shouldn't read anything to
you just this is the most bizarre like this just does the
most off the walls like pose position Oh my goodness.
A couple more questions if that's okay.
If I did this, would that mean anything to you?
Who did you see doing that?
Someone in the woods carving it into a tree.
That was Kyle.
Kyle!
It's a guy from the course.
He's an idiot.
And where does he live?
I can't remember.
Somewhere outside the village?
He's getting outside every single room.
The three fingers thing is something the students started
doing.
It's something from the course.
The Three Freedoms.
What?
It's from the course.
It's a phrase.
Oh my god, this place...
Free to be free.
This is a cult.
Free yourself from the things that are holding you back.
Oh, it's such a cult.
Things that stop you being successful.
What are they?
There's a fear of failure.
Guilt.
And a doubting.
A self-doubt.
You believe that?
Yeah.
Guilt ruins lives.
it stops you looking forward it serves no practical purpose
it's basically destructive right that's why he doesn't feel
guilty about killing Kate free to be free not the most
original slogan but I wonder how far this freedom goes think
if it was a middle finger it just went around showing it off
and asking if I did this to you does it mean anything yeah
Atlas phrase free to be free thank you thank you simon your
help was very intriguing actually well i should ask
everybody else too the game's gonna get mad at me if i did
this why does it look so crazed every time he does it no why
it's okay thanks it's okay it's fine that's all right do you
to be free yeah it's an atlas thing oh she doesn't like it i
first heard it when i went with simon oh she doesn't what
did they say about it they said that you shouldn't feel
guilty if you do something wrong i don't agree with that oh
no no no i think you should feel guilty if you do something
wrong what did simon think i don't know but i don't think
you agree with that either Hmm.
Doubt Simon agrees with it fully.
Oh, no.
They're going to break up.
I heard you can buy love at the store for 250 yen.
Awesome.
So cheap.
Hmm.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Huh.
I mean, she cheated.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's go back to Atlas because we're going to catch him in
his lies.
Contradiction.
There we go.
Doesn't this mean anything to you?
Try.
There we go.
Ask you a couple more things, please.
Yes.
bit about the phrase free to be free if i did this six seven
hands to be free my favorite motto well we teach our
students that people well they suffer from excessive guilt
don't they excessive self-criticism excessive doubt evils of
excess we call them and we tell our students that if they
rid themselves of these evils then they're free to realize
their full potential who came up with I have a background in
psychology honestly I don't look so surprised inspector
there's an intellect lurking in here when did you come up
with the phrase when we were based at the village hall when
I say we I came up with the phrase dad's more the money man
and very successful at it too are I here oh he's successful
but he's not a creative man dad suffers from a lack of
imagination.
I see.
Excuse me, Minto.
Does this mean anything to you?
Hard times.
It's been a while.
Welcome back!
Thank you.
Alright, let's see.
Well...
I'm gonna try.
Thanks to the fingers is a devil sign, but he was into...
Yeah.
He would know.
No, he doesn't know.
Mr. Aviyam!
Thank you so much for the part.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Doesn't know how the finger symbol could be used.
But he invented the phrase maybe?
No, why can't we say that we were told that this is what
this means?
Hmm.
Why can't we say, hey, someone from your class believes this
and learned it from you?
Come on, game.
Let me be, let me take over.
Let me be the detective.
That's all for the moment.
Thank you.
Said there's something that the students started doing.
Yeah, but surely he would say the phrase in class.
and they would like do that and he would notice, right?
Like, I feel like that's something that he would notice.
Is anybody in the restaurant?
Nope.
Slow night.
Ring a ling.
We gotta ask everybody.
Just a few more questions if you don't mind.
Does this mean anything to you?
If I did this, would that mean anything to you?
Why is it meant to mean something?
No, no, it's okay.
She's so like...
Her acting is... I can't tell if this is just how she is,
but her acting is so good because she's so aloof.
Ever heard the phrase, free to be free?
Do you mean the Atlas thing?
Yes, I have.
Know what it means?
It means being free of guilt.
What do you think about that?
You mean, do I think it's a bad thing?
Do you?
I mean, surely if you have done something wrong.
Oh, but that's the point, Inspector.
Most people spend their time feeling guilty over nothing,
and that's not a good thing.
But if you have done something wrong...
If you have done something wrong...
Be back later on, if that's okay.
Be back later on?
Say you.
Hmm.
You think she's the only one that doesn't seem completely
insane?
That makes sense.
Is it?
Oh.
Anybody here?
Anybody outside?
No.
Alright.
Totals!
Chip Cheerio!
Alright.
If you don't feel guilty, you probably do more evil.
Do evil.
Spider!
Ask about a few more things, please.
Do you know this?
If I did that, would it mean anything to you yeah it's a
satanism symbol satanists use it have you ever seen anyone
using it lots of people politicians presidents ceos have you
ever seen anyone local using it not that i remember
everybody's using the symbol no you guys it literally is
love in sign language at least American Sign Language.
Minky said it meant love.
It does!
It's love in American Sign Language.
Hasn't seen anyone locally using it.
Well, honestly, do you meet anyone locally?
Do you see anyone in this town?
Oh, whoops, dig it!
I didn't mean to do that.
I meant to ask him them.
Because I think there's only like three people in this town
and you guys never It seemed to interact.
It's okay.
Ever hear the phrase, free to be free?
Heard anyone use that?
Nah.
What is it?
A song?
No, I don't think so.
Doesn't matter.
Oh.
Never heard the phrase.
All right.
Let's go ask the chief maybe he knows of direction he wants
me to go in with this.
I'm gonna call the chief.
Chief?
Help.
Chief, pick up.
It's so funny to imagine this guy constantly entering and
leaving people's houses all within the span of like an hour.
Which is the word.
It's only 7 p.m.
We got here at 5.
In the span of two hours, we have gone to this...
Alright, help me, help me, him.
Yes, Mito, what do you need?
Sorry for not picking up.
I need a British expert.
Better try the woods again.
Okay, game.
It really, it really is, like, if you don't know what to do,
go back to the woods.
Over here?
Oh my god.
Who are you?
What are you?
Private eye?
Yeah.
Uh, no, I'm a police inspector.
Who are you looking for?
I'm investigating a death in the village.
That student then.
They did one last year too.
Same place.
What?
Did what?
A ritual?
Drowned a student.
Oh!
Ask that psycho about it.
He runs that business cult thing up at the...
It's a big house.
Ah!
A bunch of nutjobs.
Y'all.
Hey, what was the student's name?
Liam.
Liam!
Oh, sorry.
How can you leave that hobo's bottle alone too?
Atlas's reputation precedes them.
I think I might call the station.
Find out a bit more about this.
Liam.
We were so right the whole time!
We were so right!
Hello, DCI Jones speaking.
Mike, it's Jenks.
Alright, Jenks, I thought you'd clocked off tonight.
Yeah, the chief's putting you on a case tonight, the Edenton
girl.
Friday night, you poor sod.
I thought that was sorted out anyway.
I wish it was.
Listen, are you near a computer?
I can be.
Yeah, go on.
Do you know anything about a death last year?
Someone called Liam in Edenton Village?
I don't remember it.
Hang on, something like that.
Edenton Village.
Oh!
Liam Rogers says suicide suicide I've gone two suicides in
two years both on Edenton oh blimey you've got your work
blimey right well good luck with that and see you Monday
thanks Mike oh wow Liam okay buddy the cross little doodle
somebody actually died two people people have died now.
I don't think that's...
Liam's death.
You can just imagine him on the side of the road sketching
out the little tombstone.
He's just like...
La la la.
Liam's death.
Spider.
Do you know about Liam?
Did you know Liam?
Liam who?
died you mean Liam who killed himself yeah he was in my ear
on a different course what course was Liam on can't remember
not mine Liam who died plant science oh first time I knew
about Liam was when he killed himself right so you don't
know anything about plants but you studied plant science
this guy is a load of shit James James degrees in plant
science but he doesn't know much about plants uh-huh so your
degree is in plant science but you don't seem to know
anything about plants well still got a lot to learn if
salvia is legal then you've never heard of salvia didn't say
that so you have maybe maybe if it's legal then why would
you lie it's legal why not oh yeah see what do you do with
it use it for explorative purposes Is Sylvia like a...
Does this involve anybody else?
Why?
Do you sell it or give it to anybody else?
Sure.
Yeah, it's just for me, nobody else.
And that's the only drug you grow, is it?
Feel free to go and look if you want.
It's okay, I'll look later.
The only drug he grows...
Not sure I believe that, James.
Then again, would someone growing illegal drugs bother
growing a legal one?
Mm-hmm.
So, it's updated.
Doesn't grow any other drugs.
Uses salvia for meditation.
Grows salvia for his private use only.
I don't think we have anything else for that.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Shroom's level.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
I only hear about, like, celebrities going to try the IUS
guy, and they're like, changed my life.
You're like, okay.
Let's go ask Rebecca about Liam.
Ask you a couple more things, please.
Liam.
Wait, okay, yeah, yeah.
Ask.
What do you know about Liam?
You mean Liam who took his life?
He used to play in a band, Black Rock or something.
No, Black Stone.
Black Stone.
Yeah, yeah, I used to let them play in here sometimes at the
weekends.
They were quite good.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Did you know there was anything wrong?
I mean, why he might have?
No, I didn't know him very well.
I didn't know him very well.
But you let them.
You let them in.
You let them play every week and you don't know.
You didn't talk to him ever.
Hmm.
Blackstone shooter.
The hand gesture.
What about it?
We already did that
Okay, that's all for the moment.
Thank you.
I think we're good.
Let's go to Simon and Emma Emma's gonna be like I also dated
him a few more questions if you don't mind What do you know
about a student called Liam committed suicide last year?
Um, only that I didn't know really what Oh, yeah, you said
that about everybody.
Okay.
Wow.
That's really it.
That's okay.
Simon's old brood.
I was kind of...
What do you know about Liam?
Liam.
Look, lad.
Took his life.
Oh, that Liam.
Yeah, yeah, I heard about him.
But you didn't know him.
No, I know he went to college, but didn't really know him.
Didn't know him.
It's sad, though.
Okay.
Hold on, I want to see something with Emma real quick.
Thank you.
It's a small town.
How do they not know each other?
That's what I'm saying.
It's a literal village.
I say she went to the pub.
Didn't she...
I don't know why I thought she said that she...
Yeah.
Went to the pub, but you don't know Liam if he played?
You know?
Oh.
Okay, I guess not.
That's what I was thinking.
Because it seemed like she went kind of often.
You know what I mean?
Everyone is a murderer, clearly.
Everyone's liars and cheaters and murderers.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
DM was Simon's main customer for his homebrew.
How do you know that?
Let's see.
I wish we could just go straight to his room a few more
questions if you don't mind Liam what can you tell me about
Liam oh Liam you mean the boy who committed very unfortunate
is it did you know him oh yes yes well I say know him I met
him in the pub seemed very happy sort of person well I say
seemed happy you can't He said the same thing about Kate.
That she seemed happy.
He committed zoo.
Nobody, how is it that nobody know?
There's literally two people in this town and nobody knows
Liam.
Had met Liam in the pub.
Hmm.
Your history of psychology.
I know.
I don't think he has a background in psychology at all.
He doesn't know how anybody's feeling.
Okay.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Show me my tip.
How much does James really know?
You should call a chief for an update.
Going back to James.
James.
Couple more questions, if that's okay.
It's better.
Yeah, but what haven't we asked?
That's what I'm saying.
Let me go talk to the chief first.
That's all for the moment, thank you.
I'll talk to the chief first.
I should go find the drug guy.
I know the guy actually like told us stuff.
The one guy who's incoherent, well maybe James too, but the
one guy that couldn't help us or the one guy that's been
helpful or either is the one guy we're getting one guy we
gotta go back to the woods into the woods into the woods yes
chief bit more news right direct he does know what salvia
divinorum is but he claims it's the only drug he grows what
when yeah I didn't see anything else suspicious I'm not sure
but I doubt you could smoke the stuff I found you'd have to
dry it out first I imagine you infuse it or crush it or
something.
Do a bit of research, find out.
Does he sell it?
He said he doesn't.
Okay, I'll speak to you later, sir.
Bye-bye.
Wait, did we ever mention the salvia to the chief?
Did we ever mention that to him?
Research it.
Yeah, try it out.
See what the effects are and such.
All right, let's go...
I also imagine while we're sitting in Spitter While we're
sitting in like the room with them Like going through my
notes I'm just kind of like I'm like flipping through like
And they're just kind of sitting on the couch Like twiddling
their thumbs Like This guy gonna Talk to him Just like Going
through my notes Ah Wait so Okay let's go through everything
didn't socialize don't know a lot of these are don't know
don't know don't know didn't know about the bottles traded
his herbal tea for simon's homebrew this is the only thing
that i feel like private use but he traded it ah i got it
when you say herbal tea do you mean salvia probably so you
traded salvia tea with Simon for his homebrew so so why did
you say you didn't give salvia to anybody else did you give
it to anybody else oh how many people did you give it to did
you give it to Kate no no about Liam didn't have anything to
do with him dying if that's what you mean so you did give
him salvia yes I gave him salvia because he asked for it but
that's not what killed him well he committed suicide
psychological issues that probably weren't helped by him
trying hallucinogenic drugs.
Didn't commit suicides.
You don't know anything about him.
You don't know what happened.
Okay.
So what happened then?
Do you even know about Third Eye?
Third Eye?
You don't know about Third Eye.
We don't know about Third Eye.
You know nothing about Liam's death.
I mean, forget Salvia.
Fine, tell me then.
Third Eye was a cult.
We had our very own psycho cult operating right here from
our village hall.
And I got rid of them single-handed.
Wait, what?
I'm the one who got rid of third eye.
Did they tell you that at the station?
Okay, start again.
What's happening?
What's going on?
You don't know anything, do you?
Look.
The cults, the cults, the cults are multiplying.
They were reeling in students, pretending to be some sort of
happy life course.
You know, we can make your life better sort of crap.
Then they'll put in everyone through this brainwashing
program to make them compliant.
And selling them on.
It's all there.
Oh my god.
What do you mean selling them on?
Selling them.
Like objects, commodities.
To who?
To anyone who could afford them.
Top politicians, famous celebrities, wealthy businessmen,
you name it.
What for?
If you don't get it, do you?
Third eye were making and selling slaves.
They were black market slave traders.
What?
They were wiping people's personalities using ECT,
brainwashing, cocktails of hard drugs.
Deliberately turning them into perfect slaves.
You know what slaves are worth on the black market these
days?
No.
millions and i'm talking per slave that's why anyone who
stood up to them and threatened to go public like leon was
just killed off they didn't give a damn so you're saying
leon was murdered by third eye exactly what i'm saying
that's why i started looking into it they're all saying it
was suicide but there's no way so i mean i believe that i
found out about him and how did you find out about all this
other stuff well stop me as can tell i met some of the
students you could see straight away there was something
wrong they were like zombies you know i could tell when
someone's got ect damage or when they've been through what
is it ect i mean u.s military used all these techniques back
in the 50s oh my god they showed all the same signs so did
you he ate the people braids that's what happened i knew
what went on how from what people said who'd been through it
Okay, so do you know anyone I could speak to who did go
through it?
Truth strike again!
It doesn't matter.
Why did they close down if it wasn't true?
They just closed down and disappeared overnight after I put
all the flyers up.
Bit of a coincidence.
But that was just after Liam died.
Yeah.
And do you think that had anything to do with it?
Wait, what?
Maybe, but it was the flyers that bought them to close.
Okay.
took down the whole cult yeah you investigate it it'll all
come out third eye definitely killed leon oh my god that was
a lot to take in does james really believe all this stuff
this is the first i've heard about third eye question is
what's their connection with atlas if there is one the truth
about third eye do not join this dangerous cult third eyes
third eye are grooming from wealthy and corrupt businessmen
they pretend to be able to improve your life but in fact
they will rob your identity and use barbaric methods like
ECT to wipe your memories and destroy your personality they
are based at Edenton Village Hall now why is this like super
super cult based at this tiny villages hall James took down
third eye by throwing the ring into the volcano what is
happening do not join those who attempt to expose them will
be killed like leon rogers it's the symbol it's the symbol
mind control oh my god oh my god we're going full cults
we're going all cults in let's go
i love it okay to atlas an annual founding of a cult in a
town of 20 people yeah baby straight to atlas straight to
get some answers open no open up open up ask you a couple
more things please what do you know about this not much so
you've never seen this before you don't know anything about
third eye I don't remember seeing it now you don't recognize
any of the symbols on it oh sorry what this is this guy
drives this that that's just just a terrible liar such a
terrible liar
aha Ryan you've just told me all about the moon symbols on
the mask yeah then you're claiming you don't know anything
about the symbols on the flyer it's all It's all the same
thing.
Oh, actually, yes.
Sorry, yes.
Yes, I do remember that.
Oh, I do.
So what did you know about Third Eye?
Oh, not much, really.
I see Cyclops.
He's a dirty.
That explanation was way too short.
He definitely is hiding something.
Never came into contact with Third Eye, only knows what he
heard about Third Eye.
Okay, I don't think we can press him on it right now.
I don't think we have anything to contradict that right now.
Wait, let me see.
The...
Did the mask again?
By a friend who died last year.
Liam?
Did Liam make...
Did Liam make the mask?
If this was L.A.
Noir, we could tell just from that lying expression.
I know, right!
It's not like a contradiction that...
There's no, like, contradiction about it, though.
Okay.
Yeah, it makes sense, but how do we connect the dots?
Let's, you know, did I do last year?
I'm just gonna say about the...
No, okay, I didn't think so.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
We will be back later.
We shall go around and ask about the flyer first.
Yeah, I don't think we quite have anything yet.
Just a few more questions if you don't mind.
Interesting.
Everybody's been smoking salvia and they hallucinated Leia
McGate.
It's all a dream.
Have you seen this?
This is way cookier than I thought I was going to be.
It's all over college last year.
James made it.
Idiot.
So you don't agree with what I'm saying?
No, I don't agree with anything James says.
He's absolutely crazy.
He thinks that the government has been controlled by aliens
and that we're all bugged.
He's nuts.
Aliens.
She has said that already.
being thank you aliens have you seen this I think James is
on to something oh is this the thing that James did yeah
yeah I've heard of it what do you know about all this a
third eye I think they're called I don't really know
anything about it I mean I've heard about leaves death but
all I know about three eyes or whatever is is on the spire
so you hadn't heard about third eye no sorry Uh-huh.
Knows James made the flyer.
Doesn't know anything.
Well, they'd live together, right?
Hmm.
He's lying.
Aliens?
More like aliens.
Not Liam.
Hmm.
We still haven't met Paul.
Interesting.
Interesting, interesting, interesting, interesting.
Masks are used during Atlas Seminars.
They're British.
They're full of beans.
You think Paul's an alien?
I think so too.
What if he descended to just this tiny village and has set
up shop here and he's He's an alien here.
Mind-controlling.
I just love that when a new clue is found, he walks back
around to everybody that...
I know.
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
Janks is getting his steps in, man.
Or we're the alien because we step outside the door and then
we fast travel.
We teleport to another location.
Or we stole the bike and we've been biking around town.
Ask about a few more people.
things please a flyer do you know have you seen this before
don't take any notice of that why James Wilson is a
fantasist he spends his time pretending to cast spells in
the woods he's not exactly a stable person he's larping and
um I heard that he was involved with growing cannabis really
the weed don't correct me on that so you don't think there's
any truth at all to this none at all none at all she's so
smug about it none at all
James cast spells in the woods that's so funny why is that
like an option I wish that we could use that for something
you say James is right but then you say that James cast
spells in the woods
you're all wizard James that's all for the moment thank you
I'm using my tip you should call the chief it truly is when
you're like I don't know what to press it's like either go
to the woods or call the chief so far I'm having fun with
the story of it all but I do wish it were less of a collect
evidence go around to everybody collect evidence go I am
having fun though don't get me wrong I'm
a bit lost for ideas at the moment to be honest so true not
really did I mention the student in the woods rather
obnoxious student carving a devil sign into a tree Jenks
makes it very fun yeah it's to do with the phrase they use
on the course the three freedoms Ryan said he came up with
it the three what the three freedoms it's about getting rid
of your past or something They're gonna blame the Americans.
Gonna be like, oh, those Yankees.
Okay.
Okay, Chief, I'll call later.
Righto.
All right, Chief, back to Atlas.
The freedom.
Freedom!
Eagle screech.
Righto.
Couple more questions, if that's okay.
So, we need to know more about this cult.
Only knows what he heard about the third eye.
Never came into contact with the third eye.
But this...
Maybe the mask.
Let me try it.
No.
Triple goddess.
but never came in contact.
The necklace, what about the necklace?
It's been a while since we've looked at that.
The freedom!
The three freedoms.
I'm not quite sure.
I think I'm...
Hold on.
Be back later on if that's okay.
Be back.
I'm using my tips.
There must be a contradiction somewhere!
A few more questions, please.
The Atlas poster.
Where's that one?
Was the first poster for Atlas?
Atlas name picked randomly.
Is there Atlas here?
There is like the eye, right?
The symbolism.
The symbolism is all the same.
He just rebranded.
I'm a different cult with blackjack and hookers.
I'm not a third eye cult.
I'm, see, we don't have a triangle.
We don't have the pyramid with the eye.
We have an A symbol with the eye.
And then we don't have, we don't have it.
It's not a cult, mint.
It is, it's a cult.
We're the, we're the, we're the four eyes, actually.
We're just a bunch of nerds out here growing salvia and
being bored in the countryside We're just we're the four
eyes.
We're the four eyes
Duh Well, you're gonna come and interrupt our math club like
what's
Let's see Hmm James said he didn't grow any other drug
except mint but that pub girl said he grew cannabis she did
say that but i don't think we can press him on that so so
basically you always were a kid or me and to basically like
her prompts wouldn't show up for for james you know what i
mean like we couldn't call him on the contradiction there is
that what you would do if you actually move out to the
middle of nowhere what grow a weed no if i moved out to the
middle I would try to become like I would I would I would
make my own like Bigfoot suit and try to become like a
cryptid or something you know I would I would create like I
would get really good at prosthetics and stuff and I would
make sure that I go to like populated campgrounds and things
and I would I would get pick people to get pictures of me
and stuff and I would become a local legend that's what I
would do and then I would check I would go on like TikTok
and someone's just like did you see the creature of the of
the woods they're calling it the magic mint
well mint you're already a ghost I know that I know that but
like I want to become ghosts are everywhere right ghosts are
all over I want to become there's like only one There's only
one mothman.
I want to be I want to be the one famous thing Does this
mean anything to you?
Yeah,
I want to be the the the Jersey devil the minty the minty
Madman That's what I would do guys I'm lost.
I don't know what to
The freaky foot Ghost of Bigfoot in a meadow
The Atlas name I think it is maybe something to do with the
poster
No, I didn't think it was that I'm just kind of picking
stuff Said it was in a book you found Yeah This is...
But this doesn't say anything like...
It really doesn't say like Atlas or anything.
I can't even identify what some of these photos are.
This looks like a slot machine to me.
I'm lost.
Searching for contradictions.
I'm trying!
The things that I'm trying to think of...
There's just so many props.
Wait,
wasn't this based at Village Hall?
Oh, it was, but you never came in contact?
Ah!
According to the flyer, this third eye group was based at
the Village Hall.
Is that right?
Was it?
That's where you were based, wasn't it?
Oh, you said you invented the Atlas phrase free to be free
while you were based at the Village Hall.
So I did.
So you must have come into contact with Third Eye at some
point.
You were using the same wall.
Oh, oh, he's sweating.
I'm afraid I haven't been entirely honest with you,
Inspector.
Oh, yeah, I think we know that.
Go on.
You see, Third Eye.
Was your pop-up?
Third Eye is, or was, Atlas, under a different name.
It really was.
Atlas is, Third Eye.
In a new improved form, yes.
And you ran Third Eye.
With Dad, yes.
So you must have known Liam.
You didn't just meet him, did you?
Yes, I knew him, Inspector, but don't get your hopes up.
All of this has been thoroughly investigated and cleared up.
You've been investigated about his death?
They dropped the case.
We didn't have anything to do with it.
Well, when I say drop the case, I mean, a police
investigation is one thing, but what the public thinks is
another.
They threatened to go public, and then James...
Bloody Wilson started distributing his flyers, and that was
it.
No choice.
It was an end to it.
You had to change the name.
We'd already paid the family an out-of-court settlement I
thought that was an end to it and then James and his
cronies.
They wouldn't leave it alone.
James has cronies.
We had to close down Buy a new place rebrand so eventually
We reopened.
I'm shocked they didn't leave town.
Why don't you go somewhere else?
Until now.
Yes, so you knew James Wilson too.
We knew James, but he didn't know us as such oh it was very
quick to shoot us down but he didn't do anything like
actually coming to the course to see what he was about so
james and then they kill someone again we're now running
atlas not unless he came to one of our courses and how much
of all that stuff was true ect machines brainwashing i'm
afraid that exists only exclusively in the mind of mr wilson
all we do is make better people we challenge their
prejudices and presumptions oh it's such a cult yeah the
university is here yourself a course starts in 15 minutes
excuse me inspector oh my god they're like yeah they get
like the vulnerable college kids I can't come back now well
you have my car at the moment all right all right yeah see
you later yes that was that I I have to go back can i come
with come and meet him if you like oh cool well i might come
and have a chat come with me oh oh apm oh my god
nico thank you so much for the reason thank you he does
however believe in the power of the individual when taught
by the right teacher please give these guys a boom mic or
something lapel anything please I can't see it though, thank
you for the get there!
Hello, Papa.
To whom do I owe the pleasure?
It's Detective Inspector Jenks.
Wow, it really looks like his dad.
I believe you knew Kate Vine.
Okay, thanks for the get there.
Oh, I thought all this was Delta, Inspector.
You do know that Kate Vine was a gherkin short of a big mat.
You do now.
You must forgive my son, Inspector.
He still can't summon up the courage to come straight to the
point.
So what do you want to know?
Well, a few more questions if you don't mind.
Oh, but I do mind.
I'm a very busy man.
Try asking an intelligent question.
Like, do I mind being quizzed about a once promising student
who turned into a useless drunk?
Ryan, would you mind leaving us for a while?
Oh.
I'll go back to the centre.
I have one or two things to prepare.
One of my favorite games.
Yeah, couple, thank you.
Adrigo, thank you.
You may begin, Mr. Holmes, although I'm not going to be able
to help you.
I don't have much to do with the course nowadays, so I can't
give you any hard information.
That's as maybe.
But we need.
No, that's as is.
Oh my god, this guy.
But if you want my opinion.
He might be our toughest nut to crack.
I'd be quite happy to give it to you.
So, far away.
Okay.
Thank you.
Okay, yeah.
Come on, thank you!
Well, Paul certainly doesn't take any prisoners.
It's obvious who's pulling the strings in this family.
And I wonder what they got up to in their previous guise as
third eye.
Eight o'clock already.
Don't I have until like midnight to solve this?
Right?
Alright, let's start at... Oh my gosh, we have so many
things to ask about.
We start at the very beginning!
How well did you know, Kate?
Harding you went at all.
I met her a few times.
but the cause that's about all so when was the last time you
saw her last friday so when she the day she died that's the
day she died was the last time speak to her then you saw her
got it it's possible and how did she seem was she happy sad
preoccupied she was drunk
kate was drunk okay okay her driver's license.
Do you know if Kate had lost this?
It's her driving license.
Oh, I don't know that.
You didn't see it lying around anywhere.
No.
Okay, very straight to the point.
The bicycle.
Oh my god, I can't believe we're asking about this.
Did you know anything about Simon Thompson's bike?
No.
Honestly, I feel like that should be everybody's answer.
Just no.
I don't know.
I don't know about his bike.
Ever tried Simon's finger?
Why aren't you asking me?
Simon Thompson?
No, I haven't.
I wouldn't touch anything that has had Simon's fingers in
it.
Ooh.
He doesn't like Simon?
That's what I'm getting from that.
Have you seen this before?
Looks familiar.
Where did you find it?
It was in the woods.
presumably had something to do with kate or her killer well
that's what i'm trying to establish shouldn't it be in an
evidence bag inspector in case of contamination i didn't
have one with me unfortunately well don't go testing it for
dna will you oh it's got yours all over it she speaks like
snape like how alan rickman played a snape in the movies
it's got your DNA all over it.
Dang!
Oh my gosh.
You know, it might not be Cades, right?
Could be the killers, huh?
Ask.
What do you know about this?
It's a freedom necklace.
You hear it, right?
It's a symbol we use sometimes on the course.
Little bird in cage flying away.
Well, freeing themselves from their past is the analogy.
So do they get them when they join the course or something?
No, no, no, not as a rule.
I think I bought one once as a present.
Oh, not for Kate by any chance?
No, not for Kate.
I can't really remember who it was for, a birthday present,
maybe for one of the students.
Which student?
That's weird.
I have no idea.
That's suspicious.
Wait, you can't un-hear it now.
That's weird.
Bought a freedom necklace for a student.
We know the one girl that said that she received the
necklace as an unwanted present.
Yeah, and you don't know who you got a gift for?
That's so strange.
It was Emma, right?
It was, it was.
Very...
very interesting what do you know about this looks like a
mask you don't recognize it not particularly looks like a
monarch mask monarch mask what's a monarch mask monarch is a
fancy dress outfit is what Ryan goes there sometimes what
why would a fancy dress please have a creepy mask thinks
mask is from Monarch Costumes.
Ryan uses the shop.
What?
Fancy dress equals costume.
Oh, okay.
Could you tell me a bit about this?
How did it designed by an agency?
Why does everybody say that?
When was that?
Last year.
Is that when you started the business?
Yes, I suppose so.
Poster designed by an agency.
Like, Why?
I don't understand why the poster being designed by an
agency is so important.
I skipped the pub window.
You can't ask about the pub window.
Have you ever seen one of these before?
I believe it's a scrying mirror.
How does everybody know what this is?
Have I used one?
Why would I use a scrying mirror?
I don't know.
You know what it is, though.
You know what it is.
Sort of thing.
No.
Does the Atlas course use them at all?
Not at all.
Strange question.
Why would you know what it is then?
If you...
Don't know.
Or don't use it.
What did you hear about an argument in the pub last Friday?
I didn't hear anything about an argument in the pub.
Should I have?
No, that's fine.
I feel like his...
actor is too good he's not giving me anything do you know
about salvia know what this is by any chance i have no idea
gardening isn't my kind of thing rebecca would probably know
i presume you've met rebecca yes i am sure she'd enjoy
telling you what it is she's the kind of woman who likes to
feel superior would probably marry a millionaire and then
decide to run her own pub How was that?
Well, she isn't exactly a housewife material.
She likes to be in control, like Maya.
Shame, isn't it, that I'm in control of both of them?
Freaky!
Oh, dang.
I wonder if someone's not a big fan of hers.
Okay.
Have you ever heard of Salvia Divinorum or Magic Mint?
Sounds like it might be a drug.
It's a hallucinogenic plant.
Legal is a matter of fact.
I'm not a drug taker, Inspector.
I have no enthusiasm for voluntarily poisoning your brain.
And you've never seen anyone on the course taking it.
Well, if someone heard they wouldn't have done it openly.
We don't allow drugs or alcohol in our course.
We like to tell students that success is the best drug.
Success is the best drug.
Anime is my anti-drug.
It's another matter.
Okay.
Have you ever heard of Maid Mint?
Please, please don't put me in the plastic bag.
If I did this, would it mean anything to you?
an atlas student doing that oh you know so this is an atlas
thing well it wasn't exactly our idea the students started
doing it spontaneously to show commitment to the course cute
really which student did you see doing that i'm not sure was
his name kyle but he was carving it into a tree i told him
to stop did you really why up defacing public property
that's the most ridiculous thing i've ever heard what's the
punishment for that kind of thing nowadays prison sentence
oh it's usually a fine all right what about defiling public
liberty does that carry a fine too oh dear enough the
student in question argued a similar point is that something
you encourage on the atlas course we encourage people who
put ideas first and moral anachronisms second oh my god the
problem with the law inspector oh my gosh out of date well i
suppose that's a matter of opinion however you still respect
it respect it this guy acted in old british tv that's
awesome we all play by the book inspector but that's only
because of the threat of possible incarceration oh my god oh
my god at the phrase can you tell me a little about the
atlas phrase free to be free where did you hear that i was
talking to one of your students it's a little phrase we
conjured up to summarize our objectives what is your
objective if you don't mind me asking making money on the
course the objective of the course is to free people from
bondage We teach that most people are crippled by their
past, by guilt, their attitudes, their beliefs, all that
kind of stuff.
Money, money, money.
Griples people.
Feeling guilty in business is like a meat eater feeling
guilty in an abattoir.
Guilt comes from the archaic emotional centers of the brain.
It's a vestige of our animal ancestry, and that's all.
Only you.
In business.
You heed it at your peril.
Only cave people feel guilty.
What the?
I'm sorry, Inspector.
My house appears to be haunted.
Do you mind closing the door?
I'm just saying it's so casually.
Guilt has no place in business.
None at all.
I have few beliefs, Inspector, but that's one of them.
And what if you have done something wrong?
Well, that's the whole point.
Guilt has nothing to do with it.
interesting opinion oh mint cameo magic mint magic mint this
guy is so scary he creeps me out he's so scary how well did
you know Liam who Liam who took his life oh well as far as I
remember it was a good student confident that guy you didn't
notice any problems I believe he had problems at home were
you there when he died yes what and afterwards you didn't
see him after the meeting no wait what was he like there
when he died apart from being drunk or possibly because of
that he seemed perfectly happy he was drunk well I assumed
the bottle in his hand contained whiskey and not lemonade
lots of similarities to Kate don't you think drinking
depression is that normal for the students people come into
the Atlas course for quick solutions to their problems and
when they don't get them as quickly as they might have liked
sometimes their impatience gets the better I thought this
was a business course I'm not being business enough the
business is not coming fast enough Oh, wait.
Yeah, funny business.
This is some real funny business going on in here.
Okay, finally, one last thing.
What do you know about this?
So you've been graced with Gerbal's company already, have
you?
James, our local minister for propaganda.
Propaganda.
I suppose Ryan already told you about our actual previous
incarnation.
Yes.
He explained.
yes did he tell you anything scandalous unless you count the
suicide well these things happened was it your idea the
suicide third eye yeah i suppose it was as my son had
started to act deal with salesmen this isn't an accurate
scary or to give him something to do and third eye was the
same as atlas teaching business skills very similar so
liam's Didn't prompt you to make any changes?
There was nothing we could do about Liam's death, Inspector.
Any more than we could do anything about Kate's, it was out
of our control.
You can't blame me for wondering, Paul.
Two student deaths and two years.
It's called a coincidence, Inspector.
I expect they had fast food also.
But you're not investigating all the local chippies, are
you?
No, that's so different.
What?
Oh.
Wow, we...
Chippies.
Oh, gosh.
What is Chippies?
Fish and chips are the number one killer in the UK.
All that cholesterol, baby.
Wow.
I'm hungry, actually.
I'm kind of hungry.
Oh my gosh.
British fast food.
Ask Vicky, I'm gonna say, what's a Chippies?
it's the number one killer in the uk
this was great oh my gosh going over this guys okay i don't
even know where to begin okay okay that's it for now okay
bye-bye i'm leaving i just want to get out of here you creep
me out your house is haunted the feeling i might be seeing a
lot of paul tonight me too i think so also i just want to
okay better question paul thoroughly yeah call the chief
okay let's call the chief real quick i need to tell him
about this guy He gives me the heebie-jeebies.
Met the villain, left.
Please, Chief, I'm scared.
Chief, Chief!
This game has such a trip, it's so funny.
Chief, lots of new information for you.
Chief!
You know that cult I was telling you about?
Well, it turns out it was Atlas all along.
They were the same thing.
And the student...
How did you know that?
It was pretty obvious, Jakes.
Well, the student who died last year, Liam, was a student
there.
They had to change their name after he died and were forced
into an out-of-court settlement with the family.
Hi, Doug.
Allsar met Paul Rand, finally.
He's worse than Ryan.
Doesn't give a straight answer to anything.
What did he say about Liam?
Not much other than that he was drinking throughout the
course.
But you're not allowed to have it.
You're not allowed to have alcohol.
Push him some more.
See what you can get at.
yes sir thanks chief did he just say bye-z-bye bye-z-bye
bye-bye everybody's so nonchalant in this game it's crazy oh
bye-z-bye oh random oh my gosh wait is that an audi he's
also an audi driver oh no wonder he's the worst
Ah, man.
It explains so much.
Ask you a couple more things, please.
That is a random car.
He's our guy.
Oh, totally guilty for just that alone.
Yeah, yeah.
Audi drivers, they're just always so bad.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyway, we gotta press this guy for something.
It's funny, though, because you'll hear somebody say...
You'll hear people say that about, like, almost any driver
or any car, you know.
But anytime I see someone being, like, a stupid jerk on the
road, that's always an Audi driver.
Oh, anyway.
And it just solidifies my thing even more.
Okay, this guy is literally the final boss.
We have, like, so much stuff we can question him on.
Third eye is Paul's idea.
Third eye, very similar to Atlas.
Liam's death was unavoidable.
Are we sure it was unavoidable if we knew that he was having
personal problems?
Good thing I have my cute little meada.
Which brand is the most common with problem drivers depends
on where you are.
I guess maybe, right?
There's an entitlement that comes with having an expensive
car.
I think that's it, though, right?
Because I think they're like, I'm in my expensive car and I
own the road.
Get out of here!
The road is for everybody!
Okay.
It was at Atlas the night Eliam died.
Didn't see Eliam after the course.
Had been drinking all night at the seminar.
But you don't allow...
You don't allow...
Uh...
Alcohol, no?
Doesn't know about Simon's.
I was...
I wish we could ask him if he knows...
Emma.
I wanna go to Monarch Costumes.
What is this place?
Business started last year.
I like it's like possibly spoke to her, but you knew she was
drunk?
How?
How would you know that she's drunk if you...
Possibly only spoke to her.
It doesn't say that he doesn't know the pendant.
It says that he says it looks familiar.
I mean, we could try that, though.
It looks familiar, but you bought it.
No.
Yeah, like he...
It's kind of awkward, I guess, that one.
Never used a scrying mirror.
No interest in scrying.
I have no interest in scrying.
I've never scrying before.
Alice doesn't use scrying on the course.
Kids' argument.
I don't care about it.
Gardening is not his thing.
Familiar but use it on the course?
We could try that.
Use it on the course.
Looks familiar.
Alice encourages ideas over morality.
reluctantly abides by the law.
I reluctantly abide by the law.
It's such a funny phrase.
I abide by the law, but I'm really reluctant about it.
I think the drug one had something about...
Oh, let's see.
Oh, yes, there we go.
Alice said, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
He had been drinking all night at the seminar.
So if you don't allow drink or drugs onto the site, to drink
whiskey all night well yeah we did give him various warnings
did try to stop him but it didn't work but you let him stay
on the course yeah well we couldn't throw him out this isn't
a primary school inspector we're not the police we can't
enforce these rules we want to keep taking his money fees
they're entitled to stay on the course and what if they want
to take drugs As long as they do it with discretion,
frankly, I don't care if they want to wipe or inject paint
stripper all over their faces.
Oh my god.
As long as we get their money, baby.
No.
Is there a kitchen?
Why do you want to go down there and check?
Well, obviously you wouldn't mind if what you're saying is
true.
Of course I wouldn't mind.
It's past the laboratories down the corridor, but you won't
find any drugs in there or alcohol.
son's office that's where I found them I find alcohol at
Atlas or not it probably isn't particularly relevant but
it's worth a look anyway it's literally okay thank you thank
you bye-bye it's literally in Ryan's office what okay Ryan
is there I wonder if I can go the kitchen must be down the
corridor there what Paul said is true.
Hold on, I want to go in here and see if we can go in here.
He said he was getting ready, right?
Wait, oh, what about the reading room?
Are they doing their seminar in here?
Ah!
Oh!
Cult!
Feel your soul.
Voodoo doll!
Then break free.
Excellent Hannah.
Oh, okay.
Could you come back later, please?
Why are they looking at him like he's the weirdo?
Sorry, Ryan, there's a few more questions I have to ask you
yet, and I am sticking by.
They're like, what's this freak doing interrupting our cult
ritual for?
Wait, is what's his name here?
What's his name?
Scotty oh shoot I can't remember too many people what on
earth was that about look like they were burning woolen
dolls Simon doll burning ceremony what a very odd course
this is where's what the business you got the one guy that
comes and he's like I thought we were learning math
statistics chief can you come pick me Yep, I'm scared.
Chief, this is way crazier than we thought.
Oh, sorry, wrong floor.
Oh, sorry, we thought, forgot to tell you that our business
course is upstairs.
Downstairs is the voodoo ritual course.
We're so sorry.
Which one did you sign up for?
DVD.
Mugs.
A whole cup of bugs.
Oh, these cupas.
Chalices for blood.
Wow, that's a lot of plates.
How many people do you expect to be here?
Do not.
Well, there's a TV right there with a DVD player.
Oh, I think we just found the sex tape.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't wash it.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Uh-oh.
I set an X, X, X on it.
Try a DVD from the pile.
No, we have a DVD.
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
Uh-oh.
I don't want to know what he's into.
Ah!
Hello?
This is the creepiest.
This is so creepy.
I think I'm gonna get cursed.
So that's her wallet, and that's wallet that was that was
Kate's wallet and that was Liam's wallet well that was odd
look like someone pick-pocketing but why make a video of it
mmm yeah why did they video it creepy it's a DVD in the pile
Atlas fake clapping
freedom true freedom means freedom from many vices that
society has traditionally believed to be virtues
self-criticism self-doubt guilt ladies and gentlemen these
are not virtues these are sins sins of the father of a fake
morality implanted deep within our minds and collective
consciousness by governments and religions through the ages
with the sole purpose of preventing the mass stopping us
from achieving the same success, happiness, and freedom
enjoyed by those at the very pinnacle of society.
I'm sorry, somebody joined this and didn't think it was a
cult.
I'm going to show you that common morality is nothing more
than the cynical creation of an elite desperate to stay in
power.
An elite hell-bent on preventing you from reaching your full
potential.
by making you feel guilty for pursuing success but the good
news is that you can take back control you can become the
success you deserve to be by doing business atlas will give
you a unique and powerful advantage life in all its
technicolor glory can be yours all that you have to do is to
stay Embrace it.
Enjoy it.
Pay your monthly fee.
And learn to love your ambition.
Welcome to Atlas.
Wow.
Give me the business.
Wait, can I do another one?
Oh, okay, never mind.
Just kidding.
It's the same thing.
No, no, please.
It's so creepy.
Welcome back, thank you.
The eyes are so funny.
So stinking funny.
Oh, wow.
Wait, I thought you said you don't keep medicine in this
establishment.
Oh, my God.
Wait, do you guys see this mug?
Who has the cat mug?
It's so cute.
Wait, it's so cute.
Suspicious XXX DVD.
Dollbird.
Okay, this is so funny.
Oh my god.
Yeah, and they blocked off that door.
So strange.
I think, uh, yeah, I think Ryan's back in his room now.
Spaghetti doll.
Yummy.
Oh my gosh, I want some spaghetti.
Maybe that's what I'll make.
Spaghetti.
What time is it?
Oh yeah, I have time to make spaghetti.
Nice.
Or, is somebody eating spaghetti tonight?
Can I come over?
Can I possess you?
Can I eat your spaghetti?
The way they grab the discs makes me...
It gives me powerful fight or flight.
They are dangerous.
Spaghetti.
Ah.
Let's go talk to Simon and ask if he knows about burning
dolls.
Wait, what is this?
Never mind, we're not going to Simon.
We're going to go into their garage.
Let's go!
Remote control lock.
It looks like it would open up their garage door, no?
back to the woods unlock to what have we seen anything that
we couldn't open yet I don't think so
Simon I I need to know questions if you don't mind I really
need to know what you're doing in this have you seen this
before what business have you learned I'm sorry what
business techniques have you learned in this place now
please tell me What do you know about door burning?
Not on the course.
It's a ritual thing.
It's getting rid of things that you don't need.
Throw it into the fire.
And that's a good thing.
Well, yeah, it helps you getting rid of things you don't
need.
So you can move on and take control again.
It's one of the masks for.
They're just to help you get into the right frame of mind.
Just get you into the zone, you know, help with the trans.
The trans!
Yeah, yeah.
It's like...
Mind control.
We do it on the course sometimes.
It's just to help you get into the right frame of mind, you
know.
So you hypnotize yourself.
Ask a lot.
How do you do that?
Just stare into a mirror and chant something, you know, just
say the same thing over and over again.
Or you could just close your eyes and put yourself into a
trance.
Some people can do that.
And that's safe?
Well, yeah.
Hypnosis doesn't work the way that most people think it
does.
You can't just be hypnotized if you don't want to be
hypnotized.
hypnotized, but you can learn to hypnotize yourself.
I've seen that.
What do you say?
It's called auto-hypnosis.
Self-hypnosis, auto-hypnosis, same thing really.
A mirror?
Like a...
Simon was a bit too quick to play down the role of
auto-hypnosis on the course.
I have to ask around about this.
Oh, yes.
The Atlas auto-hypnosis.
The doodles are killing me.
Oh, he's so goofy.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, so.
The masks help you with the trance.
Auto-hypnosis induced by using a mirror.
Huh.
If I were to do this, would it mean anything to do?
Yeah, the finger guns.
to me sending my first of all ever to say how happy i am to
have gone on the dinosaur ride one last time today i was
thinking of you the whole time and yes i did buy the time
rover revoke a jolt car get her i'm so jealous and so happy
for you too how long were the lot was the line for you i've
seen that the lines have been getting into like the 70 80 90
minutes and you made it why would anyone join a cult anyway
two months.
Did you see the video they posted?
Who posted?
He made it.
They thought you weren't gonna make it, but you made it.
It's really funny because, like, the queue for the wait for
dinosaur is so long that people are seeing parts of the
queue that they've never seen before.
They're like, wow, I didn't even know that, like, this part,
this area existed.
There's, like, cute little, like, dinosaur statues and stuff
around.
It's so awesome.
It was 75 minutes consistently, but I had lightning laying.
Tomorrow's the last day, you guys.
That dinosaur, like, you can ride dinosaur.
That's so sad.
Tomorrow's the last day.
It's open.
Come February 2nd, it will be gone.
Maranera and cheese, a perfect blend of me.
Hope made spaghetti is doing well.
I can't believe they're getting rid of dinosaur and they're
going to replace it with an incanto dark ride.
Why do we need another freaking slow boat dark ride?
I'm losing my mind.
I can't do it.
I don't want another dark ride.
That makes several dark rides at Animal Kingdom.
Actually, I think there's just the one.
Wait, is it?
Hold on.
But still, Disney has so many dark rides.
They're slow and they're boring and like...
Sorry, anyway.
Do people like dark rides that much?
You would be surprised, actually, at how many people dislike
bigger thrill rides.
I think that's the main thing.
A lot of people like dark rides because, one, you get to sit
for a longer amount of time because you are walking around
in the park a lot, and you get to sit and it's nice and cool
in there and stuff like that.
It's just, you know, I'm a big fan of fun, fun action rides
and stuff like that, you know?
I love, and don't get me wrong, like I can appreciate a dark
ride, like, uh, I like those two.
but like having only dark rides like that are like boat that
you sit in a boat and you just travel along and it's very
slow like it's it's a small world is voted as the comfiest
ride to sleep and due to the vibes in the ac for years it's
lame it really is lame it's just lame I mean, I know that
the ride will still be the same because it will be Indiana
Jones and it's basically the same track.
So it will still be an exciting ride.
And the Enkanto ride will be another thing.
Oh, I'm so bummed.
I'm so bummed.
Ugh.
I love it, Indy.
I love Indiana Jones but I don't think we need three parks
with Indiana Jones when we had a perfectly good ride as
dinosaur you want Indiana Jones improve the one that's at
the California parks like fix that one having dinosaur was a
unique ride now we have the same ride at three places I
don't know.
You're right.
We need five.
Oh.
It's sad when something you enjoy disappears.
Dinoland just had such a nice charm.
I just wish I could have gotten to it more.
But.
But...
Make Bint your CEO.
She actually knows...
I wouldn't say that.
I need to go to this business class so I can learn the
business.
And cast my morals into the fire.
Apparently.
My morals and my guilt be cast away so I can...
No business.
I'll be the business...
Business...
Thank you.
Probably be back later.
I'll know the most business.
than any other ghost ever.
Wait, I meant to go to Emma, my bud.
Emma, did you know that this is what your boyfriend is
doing?
I have your questions, if you don't mind.
Your boyfriend is burning dolls in the ceremony.
What do you know about doll burning?
Doll burning.
I think it was something that they did on the course.
Simon mentioned it.
Oh, so you didn't know.
Oh, they didn't do that when you were there.
Wait, so you did know about this.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Wait, so you did know?
Okay.
Have you seen this before?
no don't think so and do you know about the auto hypnosis do
you know what auto hypnosis is um it's some type of
self-hypnosis isn't it yeah have you ever tried it no I
haven't but I think Kate was into it she learned it from
when she went to Atlas and what did she tell you about it um
not a lot really I think I think she uses it as a sort of
self-meditation.
Has never tried auto-hypnosis herself.
I don't know.
I feel like what she was looking into the mirror earlier.
I feel like that's what she was doing, no?
Right.
She was, like, kind of getting freaky with it.
I'm going to see.
Demonstrated that she knew how to use it, but has never
tried it.
Maybe it's just the scrying part.
You know what, though?
Also, she knows that her boyfriend does all of this.
And yet, it's not that strange that she stayed with him
because she slept with the guy that made all of this.
So, you know what?
Maybe...
That's all for the moment.
Maybe Emma is a lost cause.
Maybe...
Emma's into it.
it emma emma emma's real into it i think maybe
stop looking for sane people here edenton's crazy a couple
more questions if that's okay okay i'm starting to get
hungry though so we're gonna ask these questions and then i
think all only that it's part of the course i i'll call it
after this interrogation dozens for him you made them oh
right can't make anything he's practically dyspraxic what's
dyspraxic mean oh ryan is practically dyspraxic what does
that mean clumsy yeah spaghetti look at that that looks like
a healthy bowl of spaghetti now doesn't it we're making me
hungry let's ask about the dvd do you know anything about
this No, sorry.
Ask Ryan.
Okay.
Spaghetti time.
Do you know anything about hypnosis used on the Atlas
course?
Are you sure you mean hypnosis or the power of persuasion?
What's the difference?
I think it's the hypnosis.
Not a lot.
But if you want someone to do something, it's usually easier
to ask nicely.
I think it's literally the thing that they brought up.
Don't all businesses use it, Inspector?
Ever heard of advertising?
Are we being hypnotized?
Are our advertisements hypnotizing us as a self-hypnosis of
the brain?
She's gaslighting us.
She's so smug and annoys me.
I know, right?
She's like, don't you think it's actually...
Don't you think it's actually...
Don't you think, actually, I persuaded you just now?
Guys, I need to go to this course that I don't know
anything.
I don't know anything about business.
I need to go back.
I need to go at all.
But guys, I also need to go make some food because I am a
hungry, hungry ghost.
And you.
You're getting very, very sleepy.
You're getting hypnosed.
Hypnotized.
Wait.
No.
I'm thoroughly persuaded you're getting hypnotized and you
want to subscribe to mint phantom made mint channel you are
getting sleepy and your finger is moving towards the
subscribe and the like button yes yes yes like and subscribe
like and subscribe oh thank you for the stream we know this
game still hasn't let you question the bike very suspicious
very suspicious indeed just don't throw your spaghetti into
a fire that's not the proper way to cook it good night good
night thank you to our girls thank you thank you seymour
thank you mr yum yum thank you why are you guys we have to
be members all of a sudden don't keep cat welcome to
membership thank you thank you thank you thank you This game
is kind of crazy This game is so silly.
I can't wait to it.
We should I think we should be able to finish it next time.
So awesome Krona, thank you.
Thank you I am hypnotized.
I had the sudden urge to send a super chat.
Thank you Sibani, thank you.
Oh Thank you so much for the redirect.
We were just ending though.
Sorry guys Dragon Rath, thank you.
I'm subscribed and membered take this instead.
Oh Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I'd rather not thank you, thank you guys!
Actually, my throat is starting to get sore, so I will head
out.
I will head out.
Finn, thank you!
Phantom Knight, thank you, thank you!
I think I need to stop drinking coffee and I need to drink
some water.
Minto is the cutest ghost, man.
I love Minto.
Thank you.
Yes, good.
Persuasion works.
Very good.
Thank you, everybody.
Have a good day.
Have a good night, and I will see you when I see you next.
Have a great time zone wherever you are.
Stay warm.
Unless you're in the Southern Hemisphere.
Stay cool.
I don't think.
You needed any help with that.
They are pretty cool now.
Oh, it's a meato!
Oh, I'm sorry.
Cash ready, promo!
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye.
Let's face that, cute!
Your tricks won't work on me.
I falls asleep in a bowl of pasta.
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye-bye!